From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Thursday, July 20, 2011. My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with videographer John Bishop on the Rutgers University campus in Newark NJ, New Jersey to do an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project that joined undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
I'm with the Library of Congress and Culture and we're delighted and privileged today to be with Mr. Junius Williams to talk about all of your work over the years and the movement and in the decades since.
So Mr. Williams, thanks so much for the welcome to the campus and it's very nice to sit down with you. Thank you.
Let me have you just to begin. Talk a little bit about where you were born, your parents, your family.
I was born in Suffolk, Virginia and my parents were music teachers. My father was the first black band director in Richmond and my mother was the first coordinator of music in North Virginia for schools.
So they had a big musical impact on my life.
Do you have parents of Virginia? My parents are Virginians. My father is from Danville, my mother is from Suffolk.
And how old were you when you moved from Suffolk over to Richmond?
I was five, I'm told. So I don't have too much independent recollection of growing up in Suffolk. Although we went to Suffolk quite often in the summer when my parents were in summer school getting higher degrees or working toward that anyway.
Where did they gotten their musical training?
My mother went to Howard University and then transferred to the University of Pennsylvania. She got a degree in music education and my father got the same degree from West Virginia State.
He was a violinist and a singer. She was a pianist and a singer.
So it was a house full of music? House full of music.
Yes, I have. Well, I had several siblings but my most immediate sibling was my brother John. We grew up at the same time. Then I had other half brothers and sisters.
So you would have been, if you moved at five, you would have done your schooling in Richmond?
I did. Can you talk a little bit about the community and neighborhood, the public school experience?
We started school a little early because my brother, both my brother and I, turned five in the later part of the year.
So my mother talked the officials into letting us start when we were four. So we were always a little younger than our peers.
We already knew how to read. We already knew how to count. So that wasn't the issue. The issue was, should they have done it?
And it didn't matter because she got us in there. Schools were segregated. She was a music teacher at the elementary schools and my father was a music teacher at the high school level.
So school was, for us it was fun. We had a good time. There were challenging moments but nothing to do with race because we were insulated from that, from the impact of race.
Partially because of our parents' middle class standing, partially because of the skillful way in which they negotiated the system to keep us safe.
So we grew up on north side of town, which was a working class, middle class area, moved from North Avenue to Barton Avenue with my parents bought a house.
And I remember high school in particular, there was a moment in which I had to decide whether I was going to go to high school across the high school in the north western side.
I guess it was more west, Richmond, I'm trying to think exactly the sector that Walker was in. But that's where most of my friends were going to Maggie Walker.
But my father told it Armstrong. My father wanted me to come to Armstrong. He said that was a better school. I didn't want to go because my friends were going to Walker. But he persuaded me to come to Armstrong.
In Richmond at that time there were two high schools for black people. You either went to Walker or you went to Armstrong.
And just to let you know how that rival played out, everything's given we had a football classic. It wasn't just a game, it was a classic. The Maggie Walker Armstrong classic.
And it was so big they had to put it in city stadium. There were 30,000 people who came to that game every year. You either were for Armstrong or you for Walker. If you didn't graduate, it didn't matter. If you associated with one or the other, you were for that team.
So that was one of the benefits of segregation. It kind of ordered our lives socially for us. We knew who we were and where we stood.
Did you have more you an athlete? Is that something that you're a football player? No, I played, well, I played tennis. The football players didn't consider that a sport. But not until Arthur Ashe became a champion. So I grew up with Arthur. As a matter of fact, Arthur was one of the people who went to Walker and eventually went to high school. I believe somewhere in Los Angeles maybe. I'm not so sure.
But he went out of town to play tennis. So when Arthur began to get national prominence as the first black in tennis, a lot of the athletes had to change their mind about that. And I was glad because by that time I had learned to play tennis. I played with Arthur a little bit, which is to say, Arthur beat me in tennis.
I think in doubles, we once got three games out of two sets against Arthur and his partner.
Did your family was it was church a part of your life coming up? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Baptist. My father taught music. I was a music director at one church and my mother had several cries at Ebenezer Baptist Church.
That's when my brother and I went. Music was a part of our life wherever we turned.
So born in 43. So by a mid-decade in the 50s, you're 12, 13 years old. Were the events of, I'm not thinking about things like the Brown decision about Emmett Till, about Montgomery.
Little Rock. Was your household a tenor in an outfit conversation away to those things? Yes, because of Jet magazine and Ebony magazine. The picture of Emmett Till sticks in my mind now. That open casket picture in Chicago when over the 50,000 people filed by it to see his bloated, disfigured body.
I was a year younger or maybe two years younger than Emmett Till and I had to just picture myself in that same situation. So we got mad, mad, mad. That was one of the sparks that really lit the civil rights movement in a lot of people's hearts, whether we did anything or not.
And then there were some victories that we had also along the civil rights front of our own making.
At a certain point, there was a festival called the Tobacco Festival Parade because Richmond was a big tobacco town. They processed tobacco there.
So it was usually segregated. The white bands were supposed to be in the front, black bands in the back.
My father said, we're not going to march in the back. And the other music teacher at Walker said the same thing. Joe Kennedy, very prominent musician in his own right.
And so we did, but at some point they said, okay, we're going to integrate it. So there was this moment when we had four high schools, two white, two black, that were meeting at the gathering point in the West End of town, getting ready to march in the parade.
There was Armstrong and Walker on two corners and then across the street on the other were John Marshall and Thomas Jefferson. Those were the two main white schools.
So of course the whites presumed to practice first and they did it with the drummers. The drummers were very mental, very sophisticated and polished rudimental drummers.
And we laughed because we knew Armstrong's drummers were precise, but we had soul and we kicked there, but there lay dead one of the great rules of white supremacy that they could do it better than we could.
And we saw it for ourselves. So we had a victory. That was our first civil rights victory in my family because we talked about that forever. And of course we marched gloriously. I mean we marched like we had never marched before. And there were black and white people cheering us along Broad Street in New York. I get tearier, I just think about that.
I'm sorry, that was enrichment. So these would have been that would have been during your high school year. Yeah, you want me to say that again? No, no, no.
Did you have mentioned to me earlier when we were chatting before we started the interview that you thought very seriously about taking music, making music you life and going to school to study music and college? How did you resolve upon the path for the animals?
Well, my father was a professional musician. He had played in some bands in Atlantic City where he grew up in other places. And he knew what the life of an artinetic musician was playing in bands. So he did not let me play in the pickup bands in Richmond. I was good on alto saxophone and people asked me to play.
But he said, nope, can't do it. I'm not going to let you play. I didn't do that. And then they discouraged me from becoming a musician because they didn't want me to have that kind of life of performance on the road.
Nor did they want me to be a music teacher in school because they said that was too precarious in terms of the money. But I wanted to be a musician. So I applied to North Western because I saw that band on television at some football game, some big 10 football game. And I said, that's where I want to go to school.
Because of the band. And I saw myself in that band. I played clarinet saxophone and drums at that point. And I was pretty good on all of them. So I knew I would have a chance at least to get into that band. So I got accepted in North Western because I had good grades. I was valedictorian in my class. I had a 3.96 out of a 4.0 average. But they didn't give me any money.
Amherst College on the other hand, which was recommended by a friend in the family who had gone to Amherst and was just graduating the year before.
Said that's the best small college in the country. I didn't know Amherst from Edison. But they gave me a free ride. They gave me the full package, full scholarship.
So of course, there was no doubt I was going to Amherst. And ironically, the music program was so bad that I put my saxophone down and didn't pick it up for most of the four years that I was there. Until one day, this guy came up from the movement one day.
Because my place was always available for people who needed rest and relaxation. Because the guy came up from Mississippi. I won't mention his name because of what I'm going to say about him.
But he had a harmonic on. He was blowing it. He thought he was a blues man, but he couldn't play that hard. So the next day, it was a Monday. I went over to the music store, which was next door to my, my, my, where I was staying in the fraternity house.
And I got a C harmonic. I brought it back. I just took to it. It took to me. And I've been playing it every set.
If you cross play, you know, the cross feel. G. I could play it mostly in G because that's where you get the full blues effect. And if you play it in C, you only on a limited basis.
And so most of us play a fourth above the piano. Most blues hop are tuned are playing one fourth above the piano play or the guitar play. Whoever's got the concert seats.
Before you even though before you even before you departed for Amherst and fall 61, the active demonstration phase, the movement had come to come into your world. And I am interested in your recollections about events around Virginia Union in 1960.
Yeah, Virginia Union 1960 or early 1961, Charles Sherrod, who was the head of the Black students up at Virginia Union University, led a series of demonstrations and
citizens at the department stores downtown Richmond, Millenrose, tall hammers, Cresquis. I'm not so sure where it was because I never got that close. I told my parents I wanted to join and they said, oh, no, the college students said they don't want any high school students involved.
When I met Charles Sherrod, I asked him, was that true? Did you guys really say you didn't want high schools students because we couldn't be nonviolent? He said no.
So that was just my mother and father's clever way of keeping me out of homes way as they saw it, little did they know.
So they whisked me off to Amherst College in 1961, but the fire was still burning because I knew I had to do something because I couldn't just let everybody else do it and I wasn't going to do it.
So eventually we formed, I was a part of the civil rights group there and we were in support of civil rights, but at some point on another it was time for me to go south. So that's what happened in 1965.
Yeah, let me ask about this is also interesting. I want to move with some care and a little bit more slowly.
Sorry.
I'm interested in, you've just mentioned this incident with your folks who were there looking out for their child and wanting to make sure that you're clear of the tensions and perspective dangers of early citizens in Richmond.
What was the relationship that prevailed between your parents on those kinds of questions and how were your views and perspectives developing in New Year's just towards the end of high school around the civil rights question?
Well, first it was Emmett Till. Then it was news about the Montgomery bus boycott and the rise of this man called Martin Luther King.
And so we talked about all those things. It was clear things were changing and of course we all knew about the brown case.
But other than those small victories that we had such as the Armstrong Walker versus Thomas Jefferson, John Marshall, little dual, we didn't see much change.
So it was talked about it until the students demonstrated. And of course my parents were in favor of that. But they thought that was dangerous. There was another moment.
At some point after the Montgomery bus boycott, the lawsuit came about that integrated said you got to integrate bus transportation throughout the south.
So Richmond complied. So one day the word went out. The buses are now desegregated.
So my parents got hold of the news and told Johnny and me because they knew we were going to try it.
They said now when you get on that bus, I want you to be careful. Don't do this. Don't do that.
And I'm sure that was the conversation held in many homes around Richmond that day with black parents trying to protect us.
So we got on the bus and sure enough we sat down in the closest seat we could to the driver.
We sat down so close that we could see the color of his neck, which was red when we sat in those seats because nobody else had done it.
Don't you just pick it up. You're just answering.
Okay, good. Where are you going to start?
We're still on the phone and we're obviously so pleased that you were talking about these.
We got on the bus and we got on the bus. And there was nobody seated in the front seats at all.
And most of the older black people were still sitting in the back of the bus.
So we sat down and we were closer enough to the driver so that I could see the color of his neck, which was red at that point.
He wasn't too happy about this.
And we started laughing and smiling amongst ourselves because we had done it.
And it was the first time that the older black people who got who were on the bus, they smiled.
They smiled at us.
Because we had done something, I get a little emotional about that.
We had done something they wanted to do for a long time.
And so after the novelty war, which was within a couple of days, we all choked back to the back of the bus where we could cut up like kids like to do.
But it was a new relationship between us and the older people by that point.
But probably after time went on, they still looked at us and told us to be quiet when we were getting to noise it.
But just for that magic moment in time, we did something they couldn't do for themselves.
And then the gradually integration just kind of stole its way onto the public transportation system in Richmond.
A couple more questions about coming up in Richmond.
Did you ever, among newer family members, or folks who knew well, as for some unfortunate common experiences of violence around grace?
We lived in a, when we bought the house, when my parents bought the house on Barton Avenue, there was a steep wooded ravine and on the other side white people still lived.
So white boys used to shoot at us with BB guns.
We in turn made weapons.
We had bamboo growing in the odds that we made, and it was slaked coming from the roof.
So we made a Tommy Hawks and spears and arrows and all that.
But we couldn't get within range to use them.
There was another street, and that was kind of comical.
One point there was a little breach.
The guys came over and I ended up getting shot in the hand with a BB gun trying to make friends with some of them.
Because I was holding up something for one of them to shoot at, and he ended up shooting me.
So I think that was a lesson learned.
So that was how I guess our moment of daytime, if you will.
Is that shooting was unintentional that he didn't?
I don't think he was, I don't think he wanted to do it.
I don't think he wanted to shoot it.
At other points he probably would have, but not at that point.
So he went back where he lived.
I went in the house and got something to put on my hand.
There was a street, though, called Brooklyn Park Boulevard, in the north side of Richmond, where whites lived totally on the other side.
And we didn't dare go across that street.
So I never went over there to test them.
We went on the avenue sometimes to buy ice cream at highs, but that was it, HIGS highs.
So that was about it.
We went to buy ice cream at highs, and my mother loved to do that.
But to other than go up there to participate as consumers in these merchant stores, that's about the only interaction we had.
I had no white friends in my own age.
I repeat that.
I had no white friends in Richmond of my own age.
We were just about totally insulated at school.
There was one Russian professor at school at Armstrong, but all of my other teachers were black.
In church, black, there were some black professionals we saw in the medical profession.
I had asthma, so I had to go to an asthma specialist, and he was black.
Except for the doctors, we saw, that was pretty much it.
Yeah, that one white member of faculty at the high school, Russian.
Did he happen to be Jewish?
I didn't take question.
Just before heading off to Amherst again, I didn't fall at 61.
That period was pretty busy with Greenboro and Virginia Union and Hill and Freedom Rides.
When did the idea of becoming a lawyer enter into your thinking and did it relate at all to the civil rights question?
It kind of stole into my consciousness that that might be something I could do.
I was at Amherst College, but my major thought was that I was going to go south and be in the movement and become a professional movement person, whatever that was.
I wanted to be with SNCC, I wanted to be a SNCC field secretary, I wanted to organize people to do whatever had to be done at that particular time.
My parents put that idea in my head.
I remember they didn't want me to be a musician, but lawyers were fine.
If I had wanted to be a doctor, they would have encouraged that too.
But clearly, I was not on the science math trip.
They said, well, why don't you become a lawyer?
They kept pushing that program because they saw where I was going with the civil rights thing.
I was telling them about things I was doing on campus.
When I came home doing spring break, I was doing voter registration enrichment.
I did voter registration in Springfield, Massachusetts, which was right around the corner from Amherst.
I had this conference called the Civil Rights Movement Reform or Revolution.
I had a group of others carried that conference out.
It was the winter of 1965.
About 1,000 people came from all of these coasts to that conference.
They saw where I was going.
Why don't you be a lawyer?
I thought about it and I said, well, maybe so, but not now.
I could see being a lawyer, being a civil rights lawyer because I knew of the great civil rights lawyers in the Brown tradition.
As a matter of fact, Oliver Hill was a neighbor.
He was a good friend, became a better friend after my mother passed.
But she went to Howard at the same time.
He was a law student and she was an undergraduate at Howard at the same time.
So living in Richmond, we went to the same church.
So it was kind of like, there's a little story there because one time we were talking,
he said he was driving through Suffolk on the way to Norfolk to argue the case for equal pay for the teachers.
And he got stopped by the police.
And so he said, the first person he called was my grandfather, Junius White.
Because he had to get somebody to vouch for him to get out of jail.
And my grandfather was well respected as a businessman, churchman in the town.
So the white people in charge said if Junius White says he's okay, then we're going to let him out on bail.
They didn't know what he was doing, of course.
They had no idea he was going down to try that case.
Otherwise, Junius White or anybody couldn't stop him from keeping him.
So that's the way that went.
I wanted to be a lawyer because they wanted me to be a lawyer more than anything else.
So this is what I said.
I will apply to two law schools.
If I get in one of those two, I'll go.
If not, I'm going south.
So they said, okay, but they didn't understand the high stakes poker I was playing because I only applied to Columbia and Yale.
And I said, well, what the hell if I get in there, I'll go.
I was not going to spend all my time filling out forms for seven law schools.
And I didn't want to go to any of them anyway.
And I got in.
But by this time Tom Hayden had approached me, but we might be getting a little ahead of the story.
Yeah, we'll come back to that.
Let me ask you to tell it's really interesting.
I have to say, Oliver Hill, that's not a pretty substantial role model.
He was quite a firm.
And the firm of Hill, Tucker and Mars, they were there too.
They were all my family friends.
What did you say, thinking about thinking about folks like Mr. Hill and his law partners and your folks in the community?
As you think back, who would you say probably, you know, that question about who shaped you most, who most influenced the way you came up and began to think about yourself as a young adult man?
My father.
Yeah, he was my kind of, I guess he was, he was my role model.
I like the way he talked to people.
I like the popularity that he had.
The kids call him pop Williams.
He would sit on the front porch and speak to everybody who passed.
My mother said, when he's speaking to them for, you don't know them.
I just like to speak to people.
I speak to people not if I see them in the street.
I speak to people.
So I would say he was probably my biggest closest role model.
What was the experience like coming out of segregated Richmond and landing as a college freshman in Amherst, Massachusetts?
Well, these are the best of times and these are the worst of times.
My mother's plan was get them out of the clutches of segregation.
You need to do that.
You need to go to the best schools.
Now, she had gone to Howard and she had gone to University of Pennsylvania.
So she had some credentials to speak about both.
My father had gone to West Virginia State, which was a land-grant black college out there.
He didn't have too much to say about this.
He, as far as he was concerned, black colleges were fine.
But she didn't want us to go to black colleges.
That was straight out her opinion.
She went to a white school and in the north.
And so she engineered that and got us ready.
We went to summer courses at various places, whatever,
whatever special preparatory things she could find.
My brother and I went to those.
And we went to camp in New Jersey and somewhere else.
So we were socially accustomed to white people, not through Richmond,
but because of our summers away from Richmond.
So there was no culture shock in that respect.
What was a culture shock was the fact that we were there
and couldn't retreat and go anywhere else back to our own little enclave
as we could after the summer was over with those other programs.
So there I was.
I wore a yellow sweater and had a big smile on.
And that's what I remember my image was.
Most of the time.
People would come up and say, you're not like most of the colored people that we know.
Or most of the Negroes that we know.
And then they'd go in and tell some anecdotal something or other
that was totally irrelevant and hurting.
And I would just smile and keep going.
And social life was absolutely horrible
because the way it was structured at Amherst and all of those other colleges,
you gotta understand, Amherst was all men at that point.
So there were four black people in each class and then that'd been that way forever more.
So there's a little mixed reaction that I have.
I really appreciated Dean Wilson who came and recruited me to come to Amherst.
And maybe but for him they would have been less.
But there was a quota.
So those who speak about against quotas, remember they have been quotas for a long time and still are.
But that's another story.
So there were four plus four plus four.
And at Smith College, there were four at Mount Holyoke College.
There were four and that there was no other, there were Hampshire College wasn't there at the time.
And of course at UMass, which was a big state school, a mile away, actually closest,
there was a whole class barrier there but they didn't have very much,
it wasn't very much different down there either.
Now I say that because most of the dating by Amherst guys was done in Smith and Holyoke.
I didn't care about going to UMass.
It was just very few people down there.
I don't know if any people in my class who were black and the young ladies at that time who was there.
And I certainly wasn't going to be the one who was going to try to do the interracial dating thing at that point in my life.
It just wasn't done.
I look at the interracial couples that I see now.
It's very casual in America, America's change in every spec.
But at that time it just wasn't done.
So whenever I was put in a situation where I had to seek out and be friends with a person of the other sex,
it was always iffy.
You asked somebody to dance at one of those God awful mixes.
I got told no more times than I got told yes.
So if I, and on those yes occasions, it was always, it's seemingly, we're not always.
But most of the times it was just, well, I don't want to embarrass you and I don't want to appear to be other than what I am.
So I'll go ahead and do you a favor.
That's basically the way it was.
But the guys were good.
I mean, I had good remates.
Other than those people who questioned me about various things.
The people that I was associated with at Pratt Dormitory in my first year were basically good guys.
Now I ran, I ran.
I participated in the rush in my freshman year for fraternities.
Because the Emirates at that time was about 95% fraternity because that's the only place you could go to have girls in the rooms or in the,
throughout the house, so to speak.
The social life in the dorms was really, really, really slim.
So that's the way they encouraged fraternities.
They have no fraternities now.
But at that time, that was part of the social fabric.
That was part of the culture, rushing in your freshman year.
So I was approached by several houses.
One of which was Alpha Delta Phi, which was one of the most exclusive fraternities on the campus.
They had had no black people in their history.
And so the other one that I narrowed it down to was the Theta Delta Chi.
And of course, they were playing the race card in the other way because they said they don't want you for any other reason that you're black.
And I said, OK, well, I'm going to go away. I feel most comfortable.
And that had to do with who were my friends who were going.
And all the kinds of things guys used to do.
So I got a bit to go to AD and that's where I went.
So I had that reputation of being the first.
And I would say that was probably the mix of what I was involved with at most times.
The mix being those people who I genuinely could get along with and who genuinely like me,
versus the opportunities to be the first wherein you really don't know what's going to happen to you
because you don't know what folks motive underneath all of that.
It was kind of like going, I imagine what it was like going to school and Arkansas for the first time.
The Little Roth Nine, except that there was a more pleasant face to the racism in some cases.
But in case of Alpha Delta Phi, it was great.
I mean, the guys were wonderful. They were welcome to me.
Except for two people, maybe three, that I kind of stayed away from.
Most of the people, if they had any ill feelings, they didn't show it.
I fit in with them and they didn't with me.
Well, ask about how you got connected there in Massachusetts to SNCC in a minute,
but it's not well as possible.
How about the academic experience?
Academics was rough.
I found out later that the schools in the South in general, not just the black schools,
the schools in the South in general, just didn't have what was on the plates of the schools in the North.
For example, I didn't have any calculus. I didn't have any pre-calculus.
The most I had was trigonometry. The guys I was in school with had already had calculus.
I didn't know what calculus was. I still don't know what calculus is if you ask me now.
But I made it through with a C.
Now, that to me was a major hurdle in my life.
A, I had never made a C in my life before.
And most of what I made in that first year, because of calculus and because of physics,
which was based on the same calculus, which I still didn't know,
that pulled away my time to study the English and the French and the history and all that.
I just didn't have time to do it because I was scrambling trying to get that math.
So I ended up with a C average, but I didn't give it a lower C.
I had no Ds. I never had a D on my transcript.
But of course, that kind of ruined my, my, my, my, my, my, the possibilities of me getting really, really, really, really high grade average
because for two semesters, I had two courses, four credits, each set sixteen credits,
over C of one kind or another.
I don't even know if it was a solid C, but it was in that C range, 75, 74, whatever it was.
So my grades suffered and my ego suffered because I thought I was dumb.
I thought I wasn't able to learn because I just couldn't catch on to some of the stuff that was done.
At one point in my second semester, the, I had a math professor named Bailey Brown.
And Professor Brown gave a midterm exam in calculus.
And I had written the answer and I looked at it and then I just exited out and put something else down.
So he went over my paper and he looked at it and said,
you had the right answer and gave me an A.
Because I had it, I just did not have the confidence in myself to know that I had actually understood it to put it down on the paper.
So I went around campus telling everybody, ooh, I got an A in calculus, everybody's, ah, junior's got an A in calculus.
So we celebrated that for a minute until it was time to go into something else.
And then in the final exam, I had three exams in two days, physics, calculus, and history.
I think two in one day of one was on the third and I fell asleep and I couldn't study for the calculus.
So I ended up failing the exam.
So an A plus an F gives you what? A C. I couldn't get away from that C no matter what.
How well I had done, I ended up falling down.
But finally when I got out of my freshman year and my sophomore year, I began to get some Bs along with some Cs.
Junior year, more Bs. And until my senior year, I got Bs and As.
Because I was into some areas that I felt better with and I had more confidence.
I got into political science, for example.
I took economics from a professor who won economics school.
The first economics school I took I got a C plus in it.
But then I met, I heard about this man named Colston Warne, professor Warren.
And because of my work in the movement in 1964, I worked in Harlem.
And I was there with Julian T. Houston and some other people whose names will come back to me.
But Julian T. Houston and Pigeon, Norman Cousins, Norman Cousins daughter.
I can't take them anything else right now, but Pigeon. That was a nickname.
So we were always discussing the civil rights movement, but these young people knew the whole movement.
The whole Marxist context, which was up to that point and an aftermath to me,
because Marxism was something you automatically against.
You didn't think about Karl Marx's anything genuine or good.
But these kids, they understood it. They weren't Marxists, but they understood Marxist analysis.
And so they were applying that to the civil rights movement.
And I couldn't keep up. So I said I better go back and find out something.
I went into Colston Warne's course. And of course, he explained a lot of things that I just didn't know.
So I got an end at Colston.
And that was the first time that I read anything by Karl Marx, but I also read all the other great economic treatises that I hadn't read in economics one, which was just about supply and demand.
So I knew about capitalism, I knew about Marxism, I knew about socialism.
That was probably the best course that I had in terms of opening my eyes to see the world as other people see it.
And in terms, how they valued and judge what we were doing here.
And it introduced me to the whole concept of class.
Because up to that point, I had only been dealing with race.
Everything was race. Things were wrong because of race.
But these kids introduced me, well, you know, you got to do the class analysis too.
So once I had that, the tool that I got from Amherst to Professor Warren, I was able to see the whole situation in another set of glasses.
How did you first get formally connected, so to speak, with SNCC and Amherst?
Well, we were friends of SNCC. We were friends of all civil rights groups, but especially SNCC, because they were our age.
So I was in charge of a group called SRE, there's another story there. Somebody wrote an article in the Amherst paper, the Amherst student.
And didn't sign his name to it. He was decrying the civil rights tactics and the civil rights cause.
So I took him on in an editorial.
And not only did I shut him up, but I got praised from my English teacher who at one point thought everything I wrote was just crap.
But he wrote me and told me that was a great example of understated emotion.
I'm proud of you, your credit to your race, and you know how to write.
That was the best thing I had ever gotten from a teacher up to that point.
I lost that letter, but that's what he said. So after that, my name kind of became synonymous with civil rights.
So they made on campus. So they made me president of the civil rights group, which was called SRE student for racial equality.
So the students for racial equality did demonstrations. We had silent visuals on campus.
And we raised money for a for SNCC and other people who went jail.
I remember one time this, Nick Friedham saying this came over and sang at Smith College.
So I went over to hear him. I met him.
Cordell Reagon became a friend of mine.
Merboh Harrington was at Smith College.
He met, she met Cordell at the same time, and they were eventually married.
That was Cordell's second wife.
Because of that same, I guess it was the same day.
So we all stayed in touch with each other that way.
People were coming up from the south with the stories about what was happening.
And we let them stay in my house. I stayed in fraternity house at by this time.
So that's how I got familiar with SNCC.
So your fraternity house, just for one small side, your fraternity house was okay with black subrides.
They stayed in my room. They didn't care.
So when did you first, I want to ask about the conference,
but that was a major undertaking. When the first comes out to do some work?
Because you mentioned Harlem in 64.
Well, the first work I did was in Richmond in 1962.
I guess it was. I was in 1963.
I was in a demonstration with one of my childhood friends, Brenda Blake,
and charge of the NAACP Youth Group, which was called the Commandos, I think.
Excuse me. That was a hip name for young people at that time.
So I was in a, on a picket line in front of the state house in Richmond.
And there was this guy sitting in the forward.
I'll never forget this, this fat guy got out of the camera and took,
with a camera and just deliberately took everybody's picture on that picket line.
And we knew who he was. He was a man from some level of government that was meant to intimidate us,
which he did. He made his point.
Then the next summer I did voter registration, I think it was within WCP.
Well, maybe it wasn't the next summer, it was the next spring vacation when I came home from Amherst.
I did voter registration.
I did voter registration in Springfield, Massachusetts during another break or kind of another,
maybe just on the weekend.
And that was the extent of my direct action up to that point.
No trip to Atlanta, you had the SNCC folks down there for a music, yeah.
No, hadn't gone to Atlanta. I just knew who the SNCC people were through the SNCC folklore.
You attended March on Washington?
Yes. I had met Marian Wright Edelman, Elliman, up at Amherst. She came to speak.
I guess she would have still been Marian Wright Edelman at that point.
She was Marian Wright Edelman, yes. And she was a vibrant, young, black woman lawyer who had worked in Mississippi,
been in the movement. And that's what she was there to talk about.
But afterwards, me being one of the only blacks on campus, they asked me to go to the president's house to meet her.
So I wasn't met her, we started talking. And she had mentioned something about Operation Crossroads Africa.
I said, what's that all about? So she asked me, we talked a little bit about that.
Operation Crossroads Africa's group sending people over to different countries in Africa to engage in some kind of civil pride.
She asked me if I was interested. I said, yeah, but I don't have any money. She said, don't worry about it.
So within days I heard from Operation Crossroads Africa, and eventually I had a scholarship.
They sent me to Uganda, where I stayed 10 weeks in a tent up in the Kigezi District.
Lots of adventures. We built a hospital, extension to an already existing hospital.
And we did it with bricks, so we helped them make the bricks. We carried the bricks.
We laid some of the bricks except on the corners they had technical students from Uganda who knew how to do the corners,
because we couldn't do the corners. And so coming back from that stay,
I landed in New York, unmanotes to me, on the day of March on Washington.
It's early in the morning, my mother drove to Washington to be with her friend, Charlotte Nash, who had grew up together.
And no, Charlotte lived in Washington. She was bringing Charlotte back, I believe.
Charlotte had come out to meet me and was in New York with her.
Maybe they drove up together and came out, I don't know how it was, but they were together as they off times were at that time.
So she said, oh, and there's March on Washington, I said, what?
I said, I want to go. So Johnny and I, my brother and I, she dropped us off on some corner, told us to meet us somewhere else,
laid on in the evening, which we did. And so for the whole day, we were there.
And we saw, and we learned, and I wanted to be a part of it.
I don't think Johnny wanted to be a part of it as much as I did, but I certainly did.
And the SNCC kids were the ones that blew my mind, because they were singing all the most recent songs from Danville.
And ironically, I had seen an old newspaper while I was in, I was in, Kigaisy District in Uganda.
And it was an old newspaper, I guess it was a London Times or New York Times or something, and I had a picture of what was happening.
You know, the violence in 1963 earlier that summer. And this was, of course, maybe a month later, when I saw it, I said, man, I should have been there.
Because if I had been in home, I'd have been there.
So that's how I, that was my introduction to SNCC, all those little pieces.
And of course, Charles Sherrod's people, they became a part of SNCC.
That's when SNCC formed and, and Raleigh that same year. So that's what, that's what that was all about.
Yeah. I wouldn't, I wouldn't guess, and say that day at March on Washington, you would not have already been a tenant to these tensions emerging in the movement between, say,
you know, Kingsfaction and the younger folks who would get John Lewis and SNCC and we're getting pretty frustrated.
Not at that time. I've read about it and talked about it and people have told me things about it since then.
Tell me a little bit more about, about in mid-February of 1965, you, you convened and organized a very, very large conference, as you've mentioned earlier, on the campus.
I'm going to talk about the conference.
Okay, we're back on after a break of the few minutes.
I had, and it's Malcolm X, I blank on those names sometimes.
Michael Harrington?
Michael Harrington and Ossie Davis. I always blank on his name. Michael Harrington, Michael Harrington.
I don't know why.
Let me say, it sounds as if you were a pretty ambitious young man to contemplate a conference of this scope and scale.
Can you talk about how it all came to be?
Well, I guess we would try to do individuals on the campus.
This is a big break, I understand you have this big one right here.
We knew from the buzz around the Civil Rights College Circuit that there was disagreement about the directions in Civil Rights.
There was black nationalism as identified and promoted by Malcolm X, which had not really come into the common day lexicon of most students, certainly not in mind.
But there was something terribly thrilling about Malcolm X, from what I had seen and heard.
I hadn't met any of the people who really knew him well as I was subsequently to meet such as Percy Sutton, who became a friend of mine, who was Malcolm X's lawyer.
I hadn't talked to any of the people who vilified him, but I knew there must be some reason why this man was getting vilified so much on television on a daily basis sometimes.
I hate that he produced, well I wanted to see for myself and the rest of us there too.
Ossie Davis, we chose because someone knew he had a great civil rights record, he was not just an ordinary actor.
Michael Harrington, because he was the man that they said, quote unquote, discovered poverty.
He was a prolific writer.
So this little committee of Oz knew these people or knew of these people.
We said we're going to really have this.
The opening session is going to set the tone for the rest of the convention.
Civil rights, movement, reform or revolution.
So I got Malcolm X's home number from somebody I knew, again it was the network.
So I called him up. He entered the phone and I said no.
You're 22 years old?
I was in 22.
This was in, we were planning for this thing, so I was 20.
I was probably 20 years old when this thing was being planned.
So maybe 20 or just, no.
I don't know.
20 or 21.
One of those doesn't matter.
You're right.
I was a young kid.
So I called him up.
He entered the phone.
I said wow, I'm talking to Malcolm X and I explained what I wanted and he said well what kind of honorarium do you have?
I think I told him $1,000 and he thought for a minute that's not very much money.
And he thought for some more.
I think I may have explained that this was important because we wanted to explain just what these are,
the emerging ideas that were coming out of the American culture, especially from Black folks, something like that.
I must have said something because he said okay, I'll do it.
I said wow, I put the phone down and it was a public phone somewhere on campus.
We didn't have phones in our rooms.
This was all done at a bell telephone with me standing there at the wall, on a wall, not even in a booth talking to Malcolm X.
I hadn't even thought about that before because I had another strange experience like that.
But anyway, involving trying to get a date with guys just looking over your shoulder.
You're standing there with this big phone on a wall and you're sitting there talking to me.
Well you don't know me but my name is so intense and I was wondering if you'd like to go out with it tonight.
Similarly, transfer that whole experience up at a notch, several nights.
I was speaking to Malcolm X and he says he's going to come.
I went back and told a group everything.
Wow.
We had similar experiences with whoever called, Ossie Davis, whoever called Harrington.
I didn't do those two and they all said they would come.
Then we had to fill in for our ordinary little breakout sessions.
For our quote unquote ordinary breakout sessions, we had all the civil rights luminaries that were coming out.
The ordinary is that we could find.
The people who were in the trenches, mostly in the south, but some in the north as well.
I still have that poster.
We had people who were in core, people who were in SNCC, people who were in northern student movement,
all of the groups that were doing anything on the cutting edge anywhere and they all said they would come.
They all did come except Malcolm X was in France when extra day trying to get into England or out of England into France.
One of those and they wouldn't let him in until he lost the day.
I got a call from one of his people saying I'm sorry Mr. Williams, but he's not going to be able to be there.
He really wanted to come and I really believe he did.
So I was down to two.
So then that day of the conference which was the Friday, I think February 12, 1965.
I got word from Michael Harrington, he couldn't make it because of an ice storm in New York.
So I said oh my god, we're going to have a thousand people hanging from the raptors in Mount Holyoke
and they're not going to come there to see me. I was cheering it. I was them seeing it.
But Ossie Davis came through because he had left the day earlier.
Got ahead of the storm some kind of way.
So he came and I explained the situation to him.
I said Malcolm can't come, blah blah blah. Michael Harrington can't come.
So he said that's okay.
I'll talk about what they would have talked about and then I'll talk about what I wanted to talk about.
And because he was the consul, he was the consulment actor that he was, he put himself into each role.
And because he was very knowledgeable about who they were, he pulled it off.
Got to stand in ovation. We got a standing ovation.
We got the legitimacy we needed because you know these colleges had put some money to this thing.
And they didn't want to see me up on the stage either holding my hand talking about I couldn't get in there.
And the conference just flowed from there.
I mean it was just just just a big success.
I met a lot of people that day that I hadn't met before.
People who were who were just folks I had heard about but hadn't really met.
Got some more intelligence about what was going on especially in the south.
But also in places like Harlem.
So it was really good.
What was your perspective around that weekend of that conference on the question of reform versus revolution?
Revolution. I was becoming a revolutionary.
I mean I was listening to all of those other pieces. I didn't know that much about it.
I didn't, for example, I told you I didn't know the class aspect of what was going on.
But this was no reform process. I could see this was going to change people's lives forever.
And it was going to change America forever.
If we got what we demanded and we were intent on getting what we demanded,
this was going to change the institutions in America forever.
And to a certain extent it did.
Nothing extra was killed.
Are we playing it?
Yes. That's Sunday, 21st.
And I always wonder would somebody have tried to kill him in Massachusetts?
Because you certainly had an overwhelming escape in all of those woods and all of those woods.
And all of those hills just coming up the hills, winding your way to South Hadley as mountains,
not mountains like out west.
Certainly steep hills and very lonely and too late in highways and stuff like that.
I said to myself, I wonder if somebody would have tried to get him there as opposed to when they actually did get him in the Autobahn Ballroom a week later.
So chilling thought.
Do you remember your reaction?
To Malcolm's death?
Absolute anger, sadness, grief, regret that I hadn't really had a chance to meet him just at one conversation.
Because I knew I would have liked him.
Just from the conversation, I liked the sound of his voice and the intensity and the honesty that was there.
He really cared about me and this conference.
That's why he agreed to come for so little money.
Not many weeks later you went to Alabama.
Right. That was February.
And in March, the same little group decided we were going to go to the Selma to Montgomery March and March.
We were kind of like done, where we've done this.
We went from visuals to a magnificent conference.
Where can we go next?
Where we got to go south.
It was time for our manifest destiny.
We had been beating around the bush.
And I had been to Harlem this summer before to work with my childhood friend, Julian Houston,
who is now a retired judge in Massachusetts.
But he was on one of those projects called the Harlem Education Program, which was associated with the Northern Student Movement.
So I hadn't had that experience, but I hadn't had the front line experience that only the south could bring.
And none of us had.
Because we'd all been in college.
We'd all decided to stay in college.
We were committed to the revolution, but you can't really be a revolutionary until you go to the front line.
So that's what we did.
We piled into a Volkswagen bus, about seven of us, from UMass, University of Massachusetts, from Mount Holyoke, from Smith and from Amherst.
And we went on our way.
So we stopped at my mother and father's house in Richmond just to stop in and get fortified along the way.
Because we didn't stop driving.
We weren't going to sleep overnight in the way.
We just rotated drivers.
And my father took a look at that Volkswagen bus.
I think we were having some trouble.
He said, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Take my station wagon.
So he gave us his station wagon, which was a big Buick station wagon.
It was full of people, seven.
And we piled luggage in the back.
And we went on our way.
Now, that was fortuitous because in South Carolina.
And by that night, we were in South Carolina.
And the guy named Fred Arano was driving the car.
And he was apparently, because the rest of us were asleep.
He must have kind of followed asleep at the wheel.
And he was going over the highway.
And the cop stopped it.
So the five whites stayed in the middle of the car wherever they were.
And the two of us who were black got in the back seat underneath some clothes and hid.
Because we did not want to be seen.
And we did not want to be caught in an integrated cop car.
So Fred, who was quick on his feet, told the cop,
we were on our way to Florida for the spring break fling that they had down there every year.
Where thousands of white kids get together, get drunk, get laid, and go on back to school.
So he took a look at Fred, said, be careful.
You look out.
You're a little sleepy, but go ahead.
Now, later on, we heard that other integrated cars got stopped.
And they never made it to the march because they were arrested on some trumped up charge in places like South Carolina, wherever we had to go.
So but for Fred's quickness of foot, he said he could have said,
we were on our way to the march.
South righteous, we're on our way to put foot.
What is it? Foot, Lord of the Day, where they had these things, the spring flings.
So we got away.
And we went on down.
Later on, we had an accident.
This big semi-trailer truck plows into my father's car.
I was driving at that point.
Just came then to front fender against the wheel.
We were in one lane.
He was in another lane, and he just turned right into us.
So we had to, the filling station was right there.
The gas station was right there.
We pulled into it as much as we could.
But the bumper was on the wheel.
You couldn't drive.
So I don't know why this guy, I mean the guy,
these young guys in the gas station didn't seem to mind,
this was an integrated group.
In the K-Way we were going.
He just fixed the car.
He just pulled it off.
We got some gas, and got the hell out of it,
because it was in some little town in Georgia.
So we kept going.
And finally got to Montgomery.
They had told us to check in with the SNCC office before going to Selma,
because you want to find out if the clan had been operating
along whatever that was at that particular time.
They were always operating, but you wanted to find out if there was a heightened watch or not.
And we went upstairs on the second floor, corner of Jackson and High Street in Montgomery,
which is where the SNCC office was.
And there were various SNCC operatives there, I don't know who they were,
who they all were.
Only when I recognized was Stokely Carmichael Carmichael.
And he said, what the hell are you going to sell my phone?
We need you here at Montgomery.
And then he explained that they were doing a parallel operation,
because they didn't trust King and SCLC.
We didn't want to get sold out on this voter rights.
So they were running a separate operation in Montgomery.
Now, as I looked back into the how the march unfolded,
I didn't know at the time that this was a SNCC idea to begin with,
because Jimmie Lee Jackson had been killed in some little town on the other side of the bridge,
days before.
And so the people were mad and said they were on the march.
And John Lewis led that march, and there's a famous picture of him being beat down.
That was before SCLC and King were involved.
King, I also found out, didn't want to get involved,
but his people were telling him you got to get in front of this march.
He didn't want to do it because the law, quote unquote,
was not on outside at that point.
There was an injunction, no marches.
But then the people in the United States got involved and pressured Johnson to lift the state.
So Johnson got in touch with the judge apparently, and the judge lifted the state
so the march could go on.
And so that's when it became an SCLC march, as opposed to a SNCC march.
So I'm putting two and two together, nobody told me,
but SNCC was probably mad anyway, because this thing had been taken away.
The third thing I learned from listening, just listening, listening,
was that there was competition from the good guys,
from within the ranks of the good guys.
And so the Montgomery was set up, just like that.
SNCC was able to do that because SNCC was SNCC.
And they had the power to do that.
They could come in and virtually take over the city,
command the attention of the police power with so much so that they could just shut us down,
they had to use all those forces to shut us down at the corner of Jackson and High Street.
They didn't let anybody out.
They were letting people in, though, which was their tactical mistake,
because more and more people were gathering.
And they had hired, or maybe they was volunteers, maybe they see volunteers,
but they had guys from the country coming in on horses with great, big, long sticks,
not your ordinary police billy club.
They were there, too, long sticks, maybe three people wide.
And they used them, they heard the cattle beat the cattle along when they were moving, I guess.
So they were given permission to knock the hell out of us whenever they wanted to.
So every time we tried to march out of their corner of Jackson and High Street,
these guys on horses and the police on motorcycles would beat us down.
I understand these guys were the clan, they had just deputized them for the moment.
I have no confirmation whatsoever, but that was what was the rumor rampant in the street.
But we didn't care who they were, they were trying to knock the hell out of us.
So I was quick enough to stay away from it, from the beating.
There was one time when we were on a little church there in the middle of the block,
where at the beginning of the block, they'd never opened this door to help us.
Never, never, never did that church open.
There were three steps going up to the door.
And we were running from the cops, running from the police.
That was the only place to go, and they had us around it.
And they were about to charge, and somebody started singing,
this may be the last time, it may be the last time, I don't know.
And that song sticks with me to this day because everybody started singing it,
and we were all prepared for whatever might happen.
But their horses stopped, their motorcycle people stopped,
they looked at us, turned around and let us go.
And that was the first time I had any evidence that there was really a guard,
because there was no way we could have stopped them.
But if I were six, seven of us could all come running to escape the inevitable.
And here it was, what it didn't come.
I had to change my mind about God at that point.
I was a member of the church, and I had been baptized,
but I hadn't paid much attention to that.
But from that point forward, I had to really revise my thinking about who was in charge on that street,
because I escaped, a lot of people didn't, I escaped unharmed in terms of physical damage.
Another time I ran from horses into somebody's house, and their door was open.
But the door was so, the door was a regular height door,
and the horse couldn't get in there.
That's the only thing that saved me at that particular time.
And on the television, I saw Lyndon Johnson in front of the Congress,
when he said, we shall overcome, talking about the voter rights of people.
And he made that famous comment about we shall overcome.
And I'm standing there looking at him, and I'm watching what's going on in that street,
and I plunge back out into the dark.
And that was in my mind that this man was a hypocrite.
Another thing that happened during that situation, a Puerto Rican guy.
He was Latino.
I think he was Puerto Rican.
Let me get some more water.
We are back on after a short break.
How long did you arrive in front of the John Lewis march?
No, it was after that.
Oh, this is after that.
Also after the meal and turnaround on the ninth.
Yes.
So you arrived for the march that is scheduled.
So you were there when the marchers arrived?
Never made it to Selma.
No, but when they came to Montgomery.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
But, well, I was and I wasn't.
I was in Kilby Prison State Prison at that time.
You had been arrested by that?
Yeah.
I had been arrested by that.
What were the circumstances of your arrest?
Well, let me tell you this one thing first about the guy with Puerto Rican guy.
The cops came looming through on their motorcycle.
One cop did drove down to the end of the street and he kneeled down in front.
Just as a protest, the guy came and hit him with the motorcycle.
But he was able nimble enough to take the blow on his left thigh and he kind of rolled away.
The motorcycle fell.
The cop was scattered all over the ground and there were no cops around.
The rest of us moved forward to get that cop, me included.
He jumped up.
This was the most brave thing I ever seen.
He jumped up and stopped us because we were supposed to be non-violent.
He reminded us this was non-violent.
We can't do that.
That cop would probably have been severely hurt that day.
And then it would have been a whole different kind of situation because they would have brought in all the police power in the state
and would have snuffed us out because then we would have been terrorist instead of non-violent protestors.
And he was smart enough to do that.
So I always remember him for that.
And he was on one leg because he couldn't move the other leg.
And he stopped that crowd.
You can't do it.
And so we all backed off.
The cop jumped up.
Got that big heavy motorcycle.
Shroom.
And drove on back the way he came from.
Now how did I get arrested?
Several times we tried to march and each time they drove us back.
At one point, King came over because the march had already started.
Somebody told King this thing is getting out of hand.
You better go to my government.
Because now more and more press was coming.
More and more media was coming.
So he came over and amazingly the doors opened and we were going to go.
And I say the doors, I mean the barricades were removed and we marched.
But he only marched us for about two blocks.
And he turned us back around.
And we went back toward the barricades.
And during that time the cops were throwing peanuts at us.
With this grin on their faces.
Though they knew what was going on.
This thing had been planned.
This was supposed to take the edge off our desired march.
Because people weren't going to be satisfied with that.
We were young people.
We weren't going to be satisfied with that.
So that same day or the next day, the SNCC organizers led us through the back door.
So they had didn't have cops down at the other end of the avenue.
We went out the back way very quickly.
We went around the side of Alabama State University.
Went in the school, emptied the school, singing freedom songs.
Emptyed everybody in that school camp.
Some professors tried to stop the kids.
Some of them just stood aside and smiled.
By that time we had doubled in size.
And now I was a mostly black group as opposed to integrated heavily with whites.
Now I was mostly black with all of the energy that that conveys young black men and women.
So then we went back to march again.
They clubbed us as we were trying to go downtown.
And at one point, this young man's, at young point, this young woman was run over by one of the horses.
So there was a guy near me who picked up a brick.
I found out later that was his sister.
I just, his sister, in terms of being a fellow black person for his real biological sister, he had a brick.
And so I jumped on his back.
I told him, you can't do that.
You're going to be killed.
We're going to be killed.
If you throw that brick, he ran with me for about a block.
This guy was about a line back of size.
And I was about 140 pounds.
But I'm talking to him all the time.
And he put the brick down, came to his senses, turned around.
The young lady got up and she was unhurt.
So I wrote a rap about that as a matter of fact that my singing group used in some of our concerts.
So that's the way I commemorated what happened at that particular time.
I told her, I said, I jumped on his back.
I said, brother, don't do that.
They got too many guns.
And that's a real fact.
As he turned and looked around?
Well, I don't remember all of it right now, but anyway.
So we went back and licked our wounds.
But then the third day, we marched down again.
And by this time, we were five or six hundred people and they just couldn't stop us.
So they decided they weren't going to bother us anymore.
Until we got downtown and all along, we were picking up people.
Picking up people.
Until we got downtown to the state house where they had the Confederate flag and American flag.
And the cops wouldn't let us, the city cops didn't let us march on the sidewalk.
We couldn't stay cops so we couldn't march in the street.
So we saw what the game was.
We just sat down and they arrested us.
There were too many people for the jail.
So they put many of us in Kilby Prison Prison.
And that's where we stayed for about a week.
Do you remember the experience in prison?
Yeah.
Worked long.
Another.
Famous.
Not so famous.
Outside of SNCC, but in SNCC.
Very famous.
We were in this big bullpen, 75 men.
And about an equal amount of women on the other side.
And so they just had mattresses with no blankets and it was cold.
And that particular time in March in Alabama.
So they just threw in a handful of dusty blankets.
And of course, the bigger guys went for them and they were just taking their blankets.
I'm standing on the side because that said I'm 40, 140 pounds.
I wasn't about to get into that frill, that fray.
So, worth long stood up on the table.
Worth long is about five feet, six, five feet, seven, I guess.
Eight, five feet, eight.
But not a big guy.
And he got on glasses.
He looks like an organizer in the whole European context.
And he says, hey, hey.
Hey, he had to haul a few times.
Said, I don't know about you, but if I was a man, I wouldn't take a blanket unless everybody had a blanket.
And it's still fighting.
I wouldn't take a blanket unless everybody got a blanket.
So by this time, people were looking around at themselves.
And one by one, those guys just came.
Pow!
Do those blankets there.
Another moving moment in my life.
Because from that point forward, we were organized.
And the cops outside the jailers said, well, we don't have no more blankets.
Well, we're told that we'll all be cold.
And everybody said, yeah, that's right.
So miraculously, they went and found some more blankets.
And brought it in.
And immediately we saw the value of organization.
That's the first time I had ever seen it so quickly.
It's one thing to thank good of yourself, because you did do what they expected you to do.
It's another thing to actually see some material results.
So that was a low hanging fruit.
Now, eventually, worth got taken from us and put in solitary confinement,
trying to integrate the church service or something.
And so that left us leaderless.
So me and a guy named Stu House became the leaders.
Stu House was a young man from Detroit in SNCC.
But he was in SNCC full time.
This was my first time.
So people listened to me.
And I was very happy with that.
Because we weren't talking about college folks now.
We were talking about folks who were in college, some of us,
but some of us who were not who speak brothers.
So I was able to learn that folks listening to what I had to say.
That was my first leadership role in the movement
was to hold that cell together for those seven days along with Stu.
What were some of the other issues you had to deal with in the summer?
People wanted to get out.
People who got swept up in and that the spirit of moment and wanted to leave.
We had to keep up the morale.
We sang.
We talked.
We refereed fights over food.
One guy went, we wanted to keep his food.
He didn't want to eat it all at one time.
So he'd hidden it under the mattress.
And somebody else saw it over there and just went over there and took it.
He wanted to fight.
So we had to stop that.
Comed it on.
The freedom song was very helpful.
We made a pact that we were going to all get out together.
But because I came from Massachusetts and because we were good at what we did.
Remember I told you we raised money for people who were in jail.
Well then it came back to me because we very quickly in Massachusetts raised money to get me out of jail.
So I didn't want to go.
So the lawyers told me if you don't use this money,
somebody else is going to use it and we don't know when you're going to get out.
We got to take you when you come.
We got to get a money attached to a person.
We're going to bail people out.
It's not going to be all of nothing.
So reluctantly I left.
Me and a few others at that time.
Say goodbye.
And by that time the march had reached town.
So we went out to the big cornfield or fairground or whatever that place was.
Where they had the final massing before going into town the next morning.
And that's where you had all the stars.
Harry Belafonte, Nina Simone.
Who else was there?
I saw.
Because I was me and a few other people who had been bailed out by that time.
We were known as the ones who were just released from Kilby State Prison.
That was our title.
So it was like the waters were part of it.
We were most welcome.
It was a rainy day.
I remember that.
Well, I didn't care about that because I was sad about those guys who were still there.
Because I had said I wouldn't go and leave but a circumstances wouldn't allow me to stay.
So we helped.
We did what we could to make the thing to accommodate what was going on.
The person in charge at that point was another guy.
I was very impressed with Ivanhoe Donaldson.
He was one of the few people I found out later who agreed to work with SCLC
from the SNCC side to make this thing happen along with John Lewis.
He was his own man.
He decided I didn't want to do that.
So he was doing logistics as he often did and did it very well.
So my impression of him was a very calm but focused young man
with a walkie talkie wearing a yellow rain slicker.
That was Ivan Holdon.
I wanted to be just like him when I grew up.
Although he was the deathwitch older than me, that was my idol for a long time.
Because I saw him take charge kind of guy in a very hostile situation.
And that's what he did very well.
So my last memory of that was people were marching in and I really was tired
physically and mentally.
So there was a first aid Jeep.
There was the last vehicle, the very last vehicle, the very last set of people in the march.
I got in that Jeep.
I was the last person because I could look out and see the road which we came.
But at that point was the void of anybody.
Because all the police by that time had cleared away the races.
But there was my thought that somebody would come up and shoot us from the back.
And if that had been done, I'd have been the one they had shot.
But it didn't happen fortunately.
Later on going back, Viola Liuzzo got shot.
She was the person who was shot last, I think, in this demonstration.
Taking people back along the highway to Selma.
Let me take the phone.
So, these are the other reference shoes of work long.
Did you know that you're in good shape in California and in the Pacific?
I talked to work.
Work was sick.
He couldn't come to the 50th anniversary.
So I talked to him on the phone.
He's in Atlanta.
Now, he did some music.
He did some ethno music colleges.
He was an ethno music colleges.
I don't know officially on that.
He went out and found old blues singers and hooked them up.
I made a movie about blues together.
Is that right?
That's how you know him, huh?
Yeah.
And I know he's known in legend and song.
But you know, not very many people have stories about him.
Yeah.
Well, there you got one.
He was a good one.
He was my man.
That was my other.
I wanted to be just like, worse.
Because he calmed the waters.
Let's take a picture.
Okay.
We're back on after short break.
You were recalling another person you met in?
Posey.
Yeah.
Posey Lombard.
No, I knew Posey from Smith.
Posey was a young white woman from Massachusetts, who was now dead because of a car accident.
Great artist, visual artist.
But she committed to work for the movement after that and went to work somewhere in Georgia.
I believe it's unique.
But she and worth were close.
And that's about all I know about worth from there.
I mean, I've only talked to him that one time since then, and I was hoping he was going to come, but they told me he was sick.
So I called him talk to him.
And he seemed upbeat.
But clearly, he was not the worth long that I knew.
He lost a step.
Do you think back to the moment when you and Stu have such shows and the kind of leader of the 75 folks in the recording room?
Nobody told us.
We just evolved.
That's what I wanted to ask.
How do you think that?
What's it about you that made you ready and attracted to the day for that leadership role in that context?
That's a good question.
I saw things were going wrong and I spoke up and people listened to me.
And the same thing with Stu.
Stu had a little more experience.
I had had the experience of running a civil rights group at a college.
He at least had had the experience of being with SNCC somewhere.
So I had no experience in dealing with folks other than college types.
But I just decided that it was something that had to be done.
So I just stepped up.
How long did you and Alabama before going back up to Canada?
Oh, right after that.
We got back in our cars and we started going back.
I guess it was the same day that the march was over.
That night, we were headed north.
Any further thoughts about the combination of the march?
Yeah.
Posey was driving my father's station wagon when I heard on the radio that Viola, Lee, Utah was killed.
Just kicked me in my stomach.
Everybody there.
We had a moment.
And there was a screwdriver in my father's car.
And I just picked it up.
And I said, if they come for me, this is not going to be a nonviolent confrontation.
After you return, you were a graduation was just in front of you a few months ahead of you.
And you would make a choice to go to Newark NJ because of the connection to Tom Aydin.
So let's turn the conversation towards all these many years that you've been in Newark NJ.
In the early summer of 65, you can't hear.
Tom Hayden was back in the Connecticut Valley, as we called it, for some reason.
He'd been there in March for the Civil Rights Conference, but he was back to Amherst doing something.
So he sought me out.
And he wanted me to come work in Newark NJ because of my work that he knew with the conference.
And he also knew I had gone down to Alabama.
So it was like my only interview for a job.
No one got it else wanted to interview me.
And I didn't want to be interviewed.
I don't even know if I had found out I was accepted at law school at that point.
I don't think I had.
So he said the Civil Rights Movement is over.
And I said, what do you mean?
He said, Selman among them, that was it.
You got to vote a rights law.
There's just not going to be anything else.
And Tom was like that.
He had kind of a pression view about a lot of things.
So he was telling me something that he'd figured out before other people had.
So I thought about it too.
And maybe within a day or so I got to let I say I was going to go to law school.
And so I said I could kill two birds with one stone.
I can go to Newark NJ and still go to law school that summer.
I'm sorry, after that summer, if I didn't like Newark NJ, I would just go on my way.
But if I did, I would call that my home.
And the law degree would be applied there.
So as it worked out, I did like Newark NJ.
And I said, I have a lot of adventures there, which you probably want me to tell you about.
But that's how I came to go there.
I went home at the end of the semester, graduated.
My parents wanted to be formal graduation.
Of course, I didn't particularly care.
So I went for the essay and went home and came back up on a bus to Newark NJ.
Did you just mention that Hayden already was looking past all the work in the south to a new type of phase of the movement.
And I know that in many respects, Newark NJ then would be a place where the movement came and found in other contexts.
Newark NJ came in North.
Did you explicitly understand that that was your project, or you came in North?
Well, I did.
The movement had already come North.
I just didn't think about it as being the movement.
Because what I was doing in Harlem, trying to build a playground with Julian T. Houston in 1964.
That was part of the movement.
The Northern Student Movement was part of the movement.
I just didn't see me as part of that until Tom brought it home.
So SDS had already been formed to do the same thing.
I mean, the ERAP projects were all in the North based on that same concept.
We have to take on what's going on in the North because it's harder.
It's more about class and their minds than race.
They were to be proved wrong.
But that was the foundation that brought them here.
These young people in the students for Democratic society or SDS, they were not Marxists, but they understood Marx.
They understood Marxism, just as Julian T. Houston and Pigeon had.
And when you applied the class analysis, they thought that racism could be overcome
if we adjusted the class background to include more people in the economy of this country.
So they came to New York based on getting people to get jobs.
When they came here, they were supposed to be working with a group called the Clinton Hill Neighborhood Corporation,
which was an older group of white liberals, mostly Jewish,
who had been in Clinton Hill, which is to the south of here, for many years, since the 1950s.
Fighting progressive cause, fighting the urban renewal, trying to make sure that there was no discrimination against blacks.
And they were an integrated group of mostly white Jewish homeowners with some black homeowners as well.
And some working, they all had a working class basis of one kind or another, but they were professionals in it as well.
So it was an interesting mix of people. But to make a long story short,
the SDS people thought they were working with poor people, and they weren't.
And the Clinton Hill folks thought the SDS people were going to just pick up from where they were,
and they didn't want to do that, so they were the split.
So by the time I got here, Tom Hayden and the other SDS people had moved down the hill into lower Clinton Hill,
where there were fewer homeowners, practically no homeowners with some, and a lot of tenants and mostly black,
mostly black working class and poor living in the same neighborhood.
So they had to already organize people when I got here.
They had been here a year and they had a base of several hundred people, maybe 200 people,
and several on several blocks.
And the issue that they came, which was unemployment, that didn't work.
People didn't want to talk about the employment status. And as Betty Maul has explained to me,
one of the black folks who I met while I was here,
the people had jobs, they were just bad jobs, they were underpaying jobs.
It was not that there was a lot of unemployment like it is now, but it was under employment.
It was the beginning of the era of the working poor.
We didn't know it at that time, but that's really what it was.
But what was wrong with people's mind was police brutality and landlords and stormers gouging people.
Because you didn't have credit cards then, people got credit and people,
the stormers were up to credit and then there was a whole lot of baits and switch in terms of the product that you got.
So that's what the end cup was doing, taking on those kinds of issues.
And how did you fund your way into a role here?
What commanded your attention?
What captivated you?
You and all this work?
You mean once I was here, I wanted to be an organizer.
I saw that as really what I could get from being here.
The SNCC experience taught me how to walk through the valley of the shadow of death
and the people who were here, but I wanted to be an organizer.
And here we were on a frontier that SNCC could really not compete with.
Because you did have that class aspect.
I understood class by this point because I had been talking about it and reading about it and studying it.
So I was ready for that challenge.
How do you get black people organized in a context that's not purely racial.
Not purely racialized.
But where you're not going to have people with white masks who are terrorists per se,
but you have the police who are doing it legally.
Where you're not going to have people who get thrown off of plantation,
but people who didn't have enough money to make their way based upon a little job that they did have.
Where you don't have folks that say, well, you can't live here because the whole area was black,
but the housing was so bad, in some cases, you wouldn't want to keep your dog there.
So how do you fight that? How do you get people involved?
That's what kept me here.
And I wanted to organize people to fight that kind of fight.
You mentioned the Newark Community Union Project, the New York Community Unity Project.
The Newark Community Union Project, the Newark Community Union Project, the Newark Community Union Project.
And it's set about this program and you also would work with Bill Hagen.
Can you describe the range of organizations trying to begin this effort in New York to find some progressive changes in the industry?
Yeah, that's a good question because Newark Community Union Project was not the first by enemies.
There were people here who were already struggling against that same array of new enemy, if you will, not new per se,
but that newly discovered array of forces that were keeping people down.
So, COAR was one of the allies of New York.
And there were various combinations of people associated with CORE
and various other organizations, the names of which I forget.
One was called Anville, ANVIL, I remember that.
And there were some black labor unions and some preachers who managed to stay out of the clutches of the then mayor, Hugh Addonizio.
So that was the coalition.
There were some white rabbis, rabbi dressers, and dragged through the mud and a CORE demonstration protesting lack of construction jobs at a school that was being constructed here at the barrenger high school demonstration.
So, you had a black and white coalition that was liberal, I would call it liberal, mostly liberal.
And the Newark Community Union Project students came on, they were the radicals.
Because they were insisted upon a form of democracy that nobody was willing to allow.
And it was a form of democracy that had not taken root in this town.
But the Newark Community Union Project people said, let the people decide.
And the people were then meeting to all hours of the night, just like in SNCC, people met all hours of the night to make most of the basic decisions.
It wasn't in the bureaucracy, it wasn't in to one leader.
Although, as it turned out, the leader was Tom.
I mean, Tom was the main man. He was the big man on campus, so to speak.
And then there was Barry Kellace. He was the big man also vying for competing for that same position.
Although they wouldn't have said it, but looking at it from the outside.
There were the community people who had their own set of standards for what they wanted to be done.
And there were people like Terry Jefferson, who you didn't really do anything unless Terry said what had to be done.
She was the office manager.
You had Bessie Smith, who was found and discovered by the Newark Community Union Project people.
And she and her husband, Thurmond Smith, were like mainstays at the organization.
That's how we got all got together and fought Badland Lords, Bratton Roaches, little police brutality.
I see that was interesting. The police brutality situation, and this is more from my review of the written record about Newark Community Union Project as written by some of the organizers.
A lot of the organizers felt not a lot of them, but some of the organizers felt the police brutality was too volatile.
Why? Because it was racial. There were white cops beating black heads.
And you couldn't get away from that.
And this was something they really didn't want to deal with because they couldn't control the emotion of the people who were affected.
And they thought it was only to arrive. So they said let's core deal with that.
So core had weakly demonstrations against police brutality because at that time people were getting beat up regularly and some people being killed.
As a matter of fact, I came to New York the first day I came. I was in a demonstration, a core demonstration against police brutality because of a black man that was shot by a cop named Hank Martinez.
Now I didn't know Henry "Hank" Martinez at that time. I didn't even associate him with anything other than the fact that he was a cop.
Years later, the same Henry "Hank" Martinez ran for City Council and won from the East Ward and he and I became friends.
I had no idea that was the same man that I was in my first demonstration against on my first day in New York, probably my first hour in New York.
I had no idea because it's completely different. I didn't see how that man could have shot somebody.
And I didn't, you know how I found out? I found out by doing some research about what was going on on that corner on that day.
And I haven't yet to talk to him about that. Probably won't.
How did you judge the course what will happen in the summer of 67 is that Newark Rebellion will suddenly dominate all of so much of how people think about this history of the city.
Prior to that point, all the spestering tension, police brutality, terrible conditions in housing, under employment and then how did you feel about your work?
Your progress so to speak against the, against the goal of starting something that we yield results. How did you feel across the first 24 months you were here?
Well, when I first came to New York, I wasn't here for 24 months straight. I was here for the summer.
And then you went to New York. Remember I went to New Haven to Yale. So you have to give me another yardstick.
And my first several weeks, I realized one thing that race was going to be a bigger issue than these kids were able to deal with.
So Phil and I were the two black college types on campus, so to speak. And we talked about it all the time.
And we were becoming more and more difficult for white people to go out and organize black people. Already, SNCC had said, I think in 1966, maybe not already, but there was a whole lot of conversation about that.
And the final act spell in 1966, Phil said, and SNCC said, white people, you got to go out and organize amongst white people.
And Carmichael replaces Lewis. And Carmichael replaces Lewis at a very tumultuous meeting where Lewis went away thinking he was the president.
And they reconvene the meeting and put Carmichael in. And that's when the whole process of the purge began.
You were there. That's that SNIC out there.
No, I wasn't there. No, no, no. I was not a part of the SNCC hierarchy. I was just a grunt in Montgomery. That's all I was.
A soldier in the Army in the Lord. So I heard about this later, but it didn't happen overnight because people were saying within SNCC and within Northern student movement and other places, white people can't do this.
Race is predominant. Malcolm X, there's a lot of what he says people didn't go along with, but a lot of it people did go along with.
And there were other nationalists raising that same issue. The integrationist in the movement were losing ground.
King was losing ground on that level because he saw it himself. I can't go out and tell him people to be non-violent in the face of the kind of violence I saw in Chicago.
And I can't keep continuing to tell the nationalists that they're wrong unless America gives me something to work with.
So that was militating against it. And we saw it on our little microcosm here in Newark NJ because of the police brutality demonstrations that just were just that far from getting out of hand because people had just taken as much as they could take and just weren't going to take it anymore.
So SNCC then felt organized SNCC in Newark NJ with the support of Tom at the second SDS office that we had in town which was in the Central Ward.
You had the South Ward which was based on the landlord tenant and the store problems. But in the Central Ward, the end cup office here was just kind of like a hangout for young men mostly.
And that's where Tom spent most of his time cultivating people here. And SNCC and Phil and eventually that became the SNIC office.
Whether it was in 65 or I don't think no, because 65 or I was still here maybe after I left in the summer it became the SNCC office as well as the end cup office.
But then Phil and SNCC began to take that separate line of black power.
So it was impossible to do anything in Newark NJ without addressing the racial issue.
And so we looked at the double ed sword that white organizers presented. Some people like to talk to white people.
They thought it was great that some white people wanted to come in and they would hood and help some people didn't.
Newark NJ at that time in 1965 was full of people who had just come from the South. This was part, this was the tail end of the second of the second great migration from the South.
So people were here who had the Southern experience. And a lot of people didn't trust white people. A lot of people love white people and wanted to be with the white people.
But that same racism that created that kind of of of of inkling within the want to be mentality also created a great deal of hostility.
And we were beginning to see the more that there was more hostility. And we couldn't get people to understand that these white people over here are different.
Took up too much time and then did you to explain that. And I found that on the block.
Because at some point I was organized I was giving my own block to work with Karenna. Karenna and I had a new block Karenna fails.
I must have been doing all right because they're signed me and Corinna to work with each other on breaking open new block over an essential ward.
The issue there was a stock light. How are we going to get a stock light? That's what the people said they wanted to do.
And amongst the people was a man named Billy. And Billy said I can work with you. But I can't work with her.
Later on Billy became a Muslim. All he already was. I'm not so sure which. But he knew the Muslim. He knew the end of the nation of Islam line.
And he challenged me. And it made me worry. Feeling I talked about it. I didn't want to stop working with the students. And I didn't.
But they rested at summer because I still believe in an integrated movement. And I thought the whole class issue was the best way to deal with it. But it was becoming more and more impossible.
You lived together. Yeah. Yeah. Was there any point at which you obviously, you know, FBI, Coentel, Pro, House of American Activities Committee?
Because you all be parts of the story open. Did you have any sense that you were already folks who were being kind of watched and monitored very closely?
I was a grunt. I was a grunt in Montgomery. I was a grunt up here in New York doing what they told me to do. Until I got my block. And I had some kind of say so what was supposed to happen there in conjunction with Karina.
A little later on, I guess it was in 1968. I look back at that point because in 1968 there was a HUAC Committee meeting. And at that point, some policeman came from New York and presented a letter from me to Tom Hayden saying, yes, I'm going to come to New York.
Now, I didn't give him that letter. I'm sure Tom didn't give him that letter. Who the hell gave him the letter?
Another and he accused me and it was really an accusation. He accused me of living with his hell-raiser, Phil Hutchings, who everybody knows as a hell-raiser because he's affiliated with SNCC.
And they were all trying to blame us for Newark Rebellion, for Newark Rebellion. That was the conspiracy. That was the context. That's how this HUAC convened took place.
The Hugh Act had lost its pop by then. They did their damage in the 50s and in the 60s, nobody was really paying attention to them. They had more important things to deal with.
But I just offer that to show you that we were under surveillance at that time. Another time I went to California to see my sister who was alive at that time living in Los Angeles.
And I came back and my bag was open. And I wondered what happened in my suitcase. A few days later, Jimmy Hooper, who was ahead of a cour at that time, knew a cour, said, uh-huh, I understand you went to California. I said, how did you know that?
Because the FBI asked me, what were you doing in California? And I put two and two together. They had searched my bag when I came back because they wanted to see if I was bringing anything in.
And the third piece of evidence also in 1960. All of this is post-rebellion where I become more than just a yellow sticky.
I went, I was asked to go on a trip to Europe to look at New Towns based on some groups interest in how they knew I was interested in housing because of the work that I had done with College of Medicine and Dentistry of New Jersey of New Jersey.
And so I was asked to go kind of as a detail. And so I got my passport and I went. And in France, I ran into this young woman named Jackie. And I was surprised because here she was in France. And here I was in France. And we have this great reunion at this automatic.
People don't know what an automatic is now, but that's the way that, you know, that was a fast food restaurant of the day. So I'm buying food and this fine lady comes up and she looks at me. I look at her and we had this big reunion in the automatic.
And everybody's happy, happy, happy. But to make a long story short, we got together later on that day and she started asking me questions about what was I doing in France?
What was I doing on this trip? Who did I see? What was I doing? Blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah. And so I'm thinking that, you know, she's attracted to me because I certainly was attracted to her.
And I'm walking, we're walking down the left bank of the same river. And she just walked on her head. And I said, Jackie, why are you running? Why are you walking so fast? And she just kept walking. And I walked faster. She walked even faster. So at some point, my ego said, I don't need this.
So she walked on. I've never seen her again. She never contacted me. I put two and two together. She was representing the man and wanted to find out why I was there and what I was doing.
She got the confirmation that she needed that I was really harmless because I really was there to look at some houses in France, England, two or three other things. Russia, we met in Russia.
So that's the kind of thing it was. Yes, there was presence all the time. And then laid on. I'm just thinking about this too.
I got permission to look at Governor Hughes' papers down in Trenton. He and I became friends after College of Medicine and Dentistry of New Jersey of New Jersey. And I asked him, could I take a look at your files because I'm thinking about writing the book.
I was with Long before I actually wrote anything down. And he gave me permission to look into his files, which was complete with all kinds of stuff from people that I knew who were informing on us to the police. And I was amazed.
So that's the way it went.
Yeah, I'm sure you weren't well, let me just check. So 65 to 66 year old. The two academic semesters fall and spring you're up in the night.
Yeah, right summer 66 here again, right 60s fall 66 up to New Haven spring the new haven. Right. And then summer of 67 back. Yeah. And I'm sure it. Well, you can tell me I'm I'm presuming that it didn't surprise you,
but were you anticipating open conflict in the streets of Newark NJ? It happened other places already. Yes, everybody was predicting it. And people were just proud of people as a bet as the weather was going to happen and knew at the particular time that it did.
But I was coming back from Philadelphia from black power conference down there. And I heard it on the turn pipe. I was kind of sleepy, but I woke up then driving my Ford failing. And so I came into the Newark NJ because I heard the city had been sealed off, but we could get in. We knew the streets.
So I came in and I think I went home that day, but the next day or it could have been that same night. I was in the car with three other guys. I think it was the next night because these people didn't go to Philadelphia with me.
And we were just riding around looking to see what was going on. And two blocks from here on the street.
Next to the AME church whose name I will remember in a minute, but I can't right now think it was court street going up a hill. I heard the sirens coming.
I looked through my rear view mirror and showing up. There was a cop cop bearing down on us. We were out after the curfew. They pulled me over.
Four guys get out, pistols, shotguns up against the car motherfucker, which of course we did.
And they searched us, found nothing on us, and then they told me to open the hood. Now fortunately, I had law books that I had forgotten to take out.
Because it was a tense moment there. And the sergeant said, okay, these guys are law students. Let them go. But the other police didn't want to do that.
Shotgun man had that gun on all of us at the whole time leaning up against the car. And he wanted to do us.
Pistol man too. But the sergeant who was supposed to be in charge had to set them again. These are law students. As is to remind them, you're going to have trouble explaining this one if you kill these guys.
Now the other guys did not were not law students, but I think he was trying to save our lives. So at some point they made a decision, hosted the guns, shot gun down, jumped in the car, torn up the speed turn right at this speed right over here, high speed, and went everywhere they were going next time.
That was the first time I looked down the wrong end of a shot gun.
We're back after short break and we swap drives if that is something you want to make note of.
I'm interested in the following. You had been in Philadelphia for Black Power Conference and you come back and tremendous tumult in the streets five days.
How did you assess what was happening? How did you think about it? How did you add it up at the time?
Well, at the time after that first encounter with the police, I tried to stay on the cover as much as I could, especially living with Phil. At some point we just left the house and went somewhere else.
We went a basement apartment, but I think they might have had the wrong address because that HUAC report has us at 642 High Street, but it was really 624 High Street.
That might be significant, just some bad policing on their part. I saw a whole lot of stuff. I saw people happy to be destroying, happy to turn the tide.
I knew something was going to happen and showing up when the police came into town, when the state police and the National Guard came in, things changed.
It was doing that second period that the police rioted, especially the state police.
At the time I was in charge of a group of law student vistas and we were working on a housing project. How do we stop urban renewal and we were investigating the whole relocation process?
That's what eventually we cited to do some serious damage to that urban renewal machine. But we stopped doing that to go interview witnesses to the police violence. That's when I really saw what the damage had been.
My law students took information, I remember one, there was a bar in the south ward where two young men had come in after the thing had been looted and we're still looking for whatever they could find.
The state cops rolled up on them. They couldn't get out. One of them hid and the other one said, okay, I'm here.
The cops said, what do we have here? This is based on the witness that I interviewed. And then they just began to systematically shoot it.
And they shot him 40 sometimes, including in the top of his head, after he fell into the floor.
So we took that information down and we thought somebody was going to do something about it because there were stories like that coming in from all over the place.
And after Newark Rebellion was over once Oliver Lofton and Animate Shepherd from the Legal Services Project, that's where I was working.
I took all this information and turned it over to the authorities. I was called before Grand jury and one of the questions was,
well, he was a part of the government's deterrent. I didn't tell you. Amiri Amiri Baraka found out, Emiri Amiri Amiri Baraka found out about this particular incident and sent a photographer to Perry's, no, to one of the funeral homes and took pictures of the corpse, which was destroyed as you can imagine.
And then he made a flyer and put it all out over town. Is this what we're going to allow to happen to all young people in town? Something worse to that effect.
So when the Grand jury, when I was called in for the Grand jury, they asked me, didn't I think it was inflammatory to pass that fly around? I said, well, first of all, I didn't pass the fly around. But second of all, don't you think it was inflammatory that the man was shot 46 times, including the type of his head?
So now I'm a smart ally. They didn't like me, but it was nothing they could do about it because they knew it was true.
So as the time went by during the actual time of Newark Rebellion, it would just became more and more stories like that and people were really whipped.
But as it turned out, the power structure was really scared of what was happening. There was a woman named Louise Epperson.
I wish she were alive so that you can interview her. But she was a person who was a homeowner, working class woman who was a homeowner, a district leader,
and a central ward right up the street here whose house was in the path of the proposed College of Medicine and Dentistry of New Jersey, which at that time was supposed to take 200 acres of land.
And she was organizing homeowners against it. And she said when interviewed before Newark Rebellion, I couldn't get anybody to talk to me.
But after Newark Rebellion, she had this twinkling eye. Everybody wanted to talk to me. So was that kind of experience? So feeling I said, well we got to do something about that.
We got a caption bottle, some of that energy that's now running in our favor. The tide has temporarily turned and our favor despite all the violence which nobody wanted.
What can we do with that image of that black man with that brick? What can we do to turn things around and make things better?
I'll have all of that. Actually before I say that next question, can you say a word about Amiri Amiri Baraka as United Brothers?
Well, the United Brothers was formed. I think the letter came out in December of 1967.
Amiri Amiri Baraka came back to Newark NJ because he was born and raised here in 1965. But then he went out to California and met Ron Karenga.
He became very much influenced by what Karinga was doing in Los Angeles with his group called Us, just U Capital U Capital S.
And he wanted to do something like that here. But he had another concept of mind of electing a black man because this was a majority town.
And he understood the whole concept of a black United Front better than most of us did. He'd been in New York and then on the front line with a lot of people who were thinking thoughts that we just weren't thinking at that particular time.
And he was in a position to do that because when during Newark Rebellion, he was beaten badly by the cops.
He had a national reputation, but not that many people knew him here except the people he grew up with.
He was doing his own work with the arts just as we were doing our work and each of us in our own little belly work.
He was doing his with the arts in a group called the Spirit House Movers. But when he got beaten and the cameras went all over him, his name became much bigger than it was.
And so he then and then the black power conference came about during the last days of Newark Rebellion anyway.
And folks said, well, you need to stop that. And they said they're not going to stop it. Wright was his name. Forget his first name.
Wright was the guy's name who was in charge of that. And Amiri Amiri Baraka became the keynote speaker at that particular event.
And from that point forward, he was the man. So he was in a position to call together a lot of people.
Most of whom were his friends from college. I mean, not from college, but from high school and other growing up here in New York.
And he included some of us who at that point had taken on a leadership position.
My position was as I told you before, I was just a soldier in the army until after Newark Rebellion, when we resurrected College of Medicine and Dentistry of New Jersey of New Jersey.
We resurrected a fight that had really been lost because the community had come together in the spring of 1967 to demonstrate at City Hall about this medical school proposed.
There was a lawsuit and they lost the lawsuit based, which was based upon the and incompletion of testimony at the, at the blight hearings to determine whether the land should be taken.
So they lost that. But during that time, I mean, the Colonel Hassan Jeru-Ahmed had, some of his people had taken, knocked the books out of the hand of the clerk.
And the people said, whoa, so everybody started coming to see what was going to happen next.
So it became, he became a cause of labor and the event became a cause of labor. And it was said that College of Medicine and Dentistry of New Jersey of New Jersey was one of the reasons for Newark Rebellion.
So I had nothing to do with any of that. I was in the audience sometime when that happened one or two times when it happened because I came down and saw it from New Haven.
But I wasn't anywhere near the leadership of that. But when after Newark Rebellion, still and I put together this organization called the Newark Area Planning Association, NAPA, NAPA.
And I had been in New Haven and talked to some of my friends at the planning and architectural school.
And I said that medical school was too large. And we started talking about an alternative plan.
The idea was they would build a massive footprint through urban clearance. 160 acres was a proposal.
I was 200 and then it was brought down to 180. And so I asked the planners, up in Yale, what's the smallest footprint you can give us?
And they said, well, we can use American medical school associates, American medical associates and standards. And we can give you a 19 acre footprint, how by going up.
So that became a rallying cry for the new opposition. So my little office over on the corner of South Orange and Bruce Street, which was an old candy store which had no heat and hot water.
We had a press conference. In addition to that, I had gotten in touch with the Legal Defense Fund. And the Legal Defense Fund said they would handle the case. So Jack Greenberg sent over a young man who was our lawyer.
The law, the complaint was going to be made to HUD and the H.E.W. based on the insufficiency of housing. The research for which had been done by me and my vistas this summer before and into 1967.
So based upon that research, we knew there was a 1% available vacancy rate in Newark NJ, which meant on anyone given day only 1% of the houses were available. But they were driving people out of their homes that they were already in so much so that there was no way they could possibly accommodate all those people.
So with a combination of the lawsuit and an alternate plan, we revised College of Medicine and Dentistry of New Jersey of New Jersey and I became a leader. So in December of 1967, before we even began the negotiations, which ended up in success for the community, Amiri Baraka asked me to become a part of the United Brothers.
The United Brothers was a group that was formed for the purposes of pulling together the community to elect the first black man. That's how we got started.
How did you swing in practice? How did you swing the successful negotiation through NAPA on the 68th Christmas public housing and job creation?
Well, it wasn't just NAPA. it was also the committee against Negro and Puerto Rican removal, which Miss Epperson had headed.
And she had other people who were from the ordinary, regular political persuasion folks who were involved in that with her. And I had the new breed with me in NAPA.
So together we had a coalition going into it. So we said, you got to sit down and talk to us. We said to the government, he had us down to his place and all that to Morven. and OK. So we were going to talk.
So we set up negotiations. And negotiations were based on the belief that they were going to let people come in and quote unquote have their say and then they were going to probably throw us a bone and the band would play on.
But we said no, we have a negotiating team. We have a nine person negotiating team. Three from NAPA, three from the committee against Negro and Puerto Rican removal and three from other organizations.
So they said, well, what about everybody else? And then we had an audience of about 200 people, most of my all supporters.
And one by one people just stood up and said, well, I want to say I want to be a part of the negotiate. We shut them up. We would not let them talk with the support of the 200 people Harry wheel and I just wolfed them down.
I mean, I can't explain it any other way. We shut them up. They had no way to go. So the people on the other side of the table who were representing the government of the commission of the new commission of the Department of Community Affairs, which was new, man named Paul N. Ylvisaker, who became my friend as well.
Ralph A. Dungan who was the head of the New Jersey Department of Higher Education and various other people who worked for them. They said, well, okay.
Over the period of months, we negotiated an agreement. And we had done our research. We had our supporters from Yale, of course, but we also brought in other people who were experts on affirmative action hiring.
We had people on housing. We had people on health. We had all so we negotiated what's been called in medical school agreements. And that's where we got 60 acres of land for vacant urban renewal land for housing, which was done by nonprofit groups here, headed by a housing council, which we set up, which Iran eventually about a year later that happened.
We said we want the model cities program. We want to have that group set up as who was set up as the advisory committee. We want that whole group thrown out because there was the mayor's buddies in henchmen. And we had an election. I was elected to that along with other people. We had that covered.
We wanted a, we wanted to set up a training program for blacks and Latinos to get the construction jobs because they were going to say, we don't have anybody. So yeah, you're right because you being discriminated against us for years, we're going to train them. And they said, okay. And we had a group of people brought together the name of which I forget at this point.
But it was a group of all the stakeholders in the jobs. We had the unions, we had the contractors association, we had the city, we had the housing authority, we had people from the community.
They met regularly to see what kind of compliance there was going on. That's the key thing. We had an entity that we set up to make sure they did what they promised to do at that table.
And all the time, the concept of that invisible brother with the brick was right there with us to let them know that if you mess with us now, you got to pay for it later. Now we never said that, but that was in their minds.
Now it's time went by that lesson and lessons and lessons and lessons, but we got as much as we could out of it.
You would contribute your efforts to the campaign of Kenneth A. Gibson.
Yes. You're like the Nolux First Black Mary. I was his first campaign manager.
1970, yeah.
So you've been through 67. You've had the reach the agreement in 68, which probably you can tell me how you evaluated that in terms of how encompassing your success was in that.
And it sounds like you managed pretty well to achieve some very substantive results.
Yeah. The only thing is we had to fight within the community to make sure that the results really were substantial.
Because if you're looking at a land here, we had 60 acres of land. All kinds of people came out of the woodwork and wanted that land.
But at that point, the white controllers were standing around watching the black folks fight each other saying, made it better man win.
And we hope it's not Williams. But we want. We established the housing council and we decided who was going to get the land.
So right now there's a thousand units of housing around that the housing council determines.
They didn't want the new construction trades training corporation to succeed.
But hundreds of young men were successful and getting a union books because we fought the unions, we fought the state, we fought the local folks to make sure that happens.
People Gus Henningburg was involved in that George Fontaine was involved in that Jim Walker those were the people who handled that part of we back them up.
They backed us up when we needed it. So those were the two most exciting. And of course the model cities election produced a whole new set of characters that hadn't happened before, including myself to become involved with a federal program of that magnitude was just 5.6 million dollars.
And we had a joint veto. If we didn't like what the city wanted, we could veto. And of course if they didn't like what we wanted, they could be to all of this came out of the agreement.
I don't think we had that anywhere else in the country.
The Houston's elected in 1970 obviously they're close to the mayor. What's your feeling about how you managed through the late 60s?
Where you stood at that point and how did you feel about prospects for the change in kind of building the world you were trying to build?
Well I was high on the results of College of Medicine and Dentistry of New Jersey of New Jersey what we were doing at the time in the street. The street organizations that we had the fact that it wasn't a democratic party group.
It was not just them alone. We had some of them with us. But the real momentum for this thing came from the people from our civil rights and black power groups that they put gifts in an office.
And I think he knew that. He said that success in the years that have followed. But when I got the job and he had promised me the job earlier, I think.
And I was happy he lived up to that. I learned the potential in the job from being on the model city's neighborhood council.
And I learned how that particular position was what I wanted if he won. So he won. And so I was in charge with planning most of the federal money that was coming to the town, which was substantial.
I was 26 years old at that time. I was making $26,000. That made a whole lot of people mad at least raise some people's eyebrows.
So there was a lot of an attempt by our part to continue what we had started in the street just to bring it into the streets.
We wanted to make sure there was democracy for the people in the city and that they got the best of whatever was possible.
So that was what was in our mind. Because that's what we grew up on.
Amiri Baraka, I believe, wanted that as well. But see, Amiri Baraka had a big heavy organization at that time called Committee for a Unified Newark, which was the main group that pulled the folks together to put Gibson in office.
But it was a cultural nationalist group. A lot of people didn't like cultural nationalism, including me. I didn't think that I thought it was somewhat artificial to go and say we're going to speak Swahili.
And then put on West African garb and we were all supposed to be there for legitimate. And anybody who wasn't doing that was illegitimate. I didn't believe that.
Because at the time, I liked the way jeans and I liked the book jobs, which I don't do now. But at that time, I thought I was just as black as anybody else.
So there was that conflict within the community that Gibson took advantage of to a certain extent.
Because he was not really one of us. He was kind of like there. But he really was not on the front line of most of these struggles.
He came in kind of like after the battle was over. And if you needed somebody, for example, he was the vice president of the business industrial coordinate council, which came out of the barren's fight.
And he helped get some jobs. Okay. So he was in. He was not an event guard. He was kind of like in the second tier.
So that was his, his, his MO and perhaps we needed somebody like that because he wasn't so controversial. But then when, when we got into City Hall, and I say we advised it because when he got into City Hall, he did not want people like me or Amiri Baraka and any kind of leadership position.
So he handled us in two different ways. Me, I work for him. So eventually he fired me because his people told him that I could not be trusted. I was going to take his job.
But all I did was make him look good. Because from that $5.6 million that I raised with the money, I was just from, I doubled that plus brought in the best, what the hood called the best housing redevelopment process housing rehabilitation project in the country called project rehab, which was another
$15 million in mortgage. So eventually he found a reason to fire me, which was based on an audit and all audit, which was dug up by a man who was running for office.
And they said, heard questions, $300,000. Well, heard had questioned that a year before he brought it out. And we were in process of answering those questions.
And it was really nothing missing what had happened was we had interpreted the guidelines one way and other people had interpreted the other way, namely the people in the Gibson administration who didn't want me there.
So I can tell you about those inventions man, we went to war with the Rep. Joseph G. Minish. I had an opportunity. Minish was in the front page of the star ledger advertising his false claim with his little subtle reference that I had stolen the money without really saying that.
And of course the people said, oh yeah, we told you, we told you, we told you, you can't put them in there. They're going to steal the money. A lot of my friends were even saying that. So then I came back, I went over to see Mort Pye who's the editor of the star ledger.
And I said to Mort Pye, you have done me a disservice because up to this point you have not listened to what I said. This is over the telephone I told him that.
And so he asked me to explain. So I explained to him what was going on. And he paused for a moment. He said, bring me down what you had. So I brought him an article. And I knew how to write press releases. I brought him the article stating what our responses had already been to the audit.
And he ran that front pages on Wednesday. All of this other stuff was Saturday and Sunday following Wednesday. I got front page. So then some of my friends came back and said, oh, now we're seeing what you're saying. Yeah, yeah, you're not too bad after all.
But Gibson didn't like that. So as I was gaining more and more support, I was on television. I was on a on this guy's show. I forget the guy's name, but it was equivalent of a Jerry spring on type show where he comes on and vilifies the people.
So I was on and he was asking what he thought were hard questions. And I was just giving him back the right answer. And so he said at the end, you know, Mr. Williams.
They're good guys and they're bad guys. And I've decided and it was a pause because he's got this rabbit audience all around him that you are a good guy.
The audience explodes. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. He comes up shakes my hand. I'm standing there smiling. My father's grin. And so the whole thing turned around.
And so Gibson at one point called me and oh, yeah, there was a yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, you're finished.
Because I said at that point in the newspaper, I said, minutes was just setting me up as a scapegoat. So minutes had to respond to that. And he says, okay, so I'm going to have a hearing. So he called the hearing.
This was before the TV experiences, I think he called the hearing and it was a tie. I mean, he had his guy come out and say that I was wrong. I had my own notes which said I was right.
So, you know, when you get a U.S. congressman into a tie in a public form, you're doing pretty good. But one thing was very clear. You asked me how I was what my what I noticed.
My controller was not there with me. He had been told by many people don't show up because they thought I needed him to get the information.
Hello, I'm a lawyer. I had been wrestling with this thing. I knew this stuff inside and outside. And everything he threw at me. I threw right back at him.
Even with nobody there on my set. None of my staff showed up my director. My deputy director didn't show up. Nobody showed up. I was there by myself.
So then after that, and after the television series Gibson calls me in and says, I want you to resign. I said, why? He said, because of the audit. I said, well, by this time I know you don't want me but I want time to answer and respond and get this thing out of the way.
And then I'll leave because I had planned on leaving anyway. I didn't want to be there anymore. And he said, no, you can't do that. I'll give you 30 days. Make a few months.
So during that 30 days, I collected all the documents that I had that I knew I needed because I thought somebody else was going to come after me with an indictment, which they never did. And I'm going to tell you why in a minute.
And so he called me in at the end of the 30 days and fired me. Now there was one more incident in that too because I was going to have a rally. And I expected four or five hundred people to come out to run a minute out of town and he told me, don't do it.
And I said, I'm going to do it. The mayor told me that to an intermediary. Of course, he didn't have a guts. He didn't have a ball to tell me this himself.
And so the intermediary came back and said, anybody who on your staff who goes to that rally would be fired. So I told my people to get the word out, but they showed up anyway. Most of them showed up anyway.
Not my top staff, but the little people showed up anyway. I had 400 people in Raymond A. Brown with the main speaker asking why wasn't the man here, Raymond A. Brown, the famous lawyer who had been the one who got Amiri Amiri Baraka out.
And who got a lot of other people off because of his excellent legal presentation.
He said, why in the mayor here and why is he trying to get rid of Williams. So anyway, the mayor had the power. He got rid of me.
So I went on to set up my law practice, but about a year later, maybe a few months later, I'm on my way to Washington for some reason. I get off the old Eastern shuttling.
And there's this little man who comes up to me and starts talking, Mr. Williams, you don't know me. But I was one of the auditors when you were the director of the Marvel series program. So I immediately stiffened.
And this guy says, he's a little guy. He says, the prosecutor came to me and asked me, was there anything there to indict this man on?
And I told him, and no one's heard in terms. There is nothing there. He turned around, walked back into the crowd, and I've never seen him since then.
True story. So that's what happened to me with this great new city experience. I was not able to apply all of the skills that I wanted to. I was able to do some things.
Amiri Baraka had a similar experience with some housing. He was trying to build, but that's a whole different story. I'll let him tell his own story.
And the mayor flopped him up with that. And as a result, he lost all of the programs that he was trying to do, including building that housing.
And he just kind of put cultural nationalism aside and decided he was going to be a Marxist. He said, I'm a communist now. And so people made that abrupt turn. A lot of people couldn't go with him.
So now he is still just as famous as he was ever was as a writer and as a playwright and a poet. But he was after that point out of the mainstream and Gibson with his non progressive politics was able to reign supreme.
Let's take a break and then we'll come back and finish up.
All right.
We're back on after short break. And I want to as we sort of look to the years beyond the early 70s, I'd really like to have you touch on a couple things.
One is your election for the National Bar Association presidency, 78. Youngest person ever elected to that role. Of course, that's the group that is the black analog to the ABA in the longest
history of discrimination, exclusion, and the latter organization. I want to hear about the love that have you sort of framed your mayoral race in 82.
And let me just leave those two things with you.
Okay.
Well, I went into practice in law after I left City Hall. Well, I just couldn't practice law. I mean, it was like, how are you going to keep them down on the farm after they've seen Perry, you know?
So I ran into a friend named O. T. Wells, who I had met at Harvard when I was speaking there. I was my own city director. He was president elect of the National Bar Association.
And he convinced me that I should play a prominent part in the National Bar Association. I believe I had gone to one meeting, one convention before that. And he invited me to be his guest.
So I became a part of it. He appointed me as assistant regional director, which was really something he just dreamed up wasn't in the Constitution.
And make a long story short because of some foul up in Los Angeles, the following summer. His convention couldn't be there. And he had no one to plan his convention. There was no staff at the NBA at that time.
So he said, Jr. I want you to plan my convention. It's going to be in San Francisco. Go do it.
So I started calling people all over the country. My dime, my time. Lawyers that he had given me the names of other people had or people I heard of. And I put together a great invention for him, if I'm going to say so myself, but he also agreed.
And I met a lot of people along the way. So that was my, my, my organizational basis, if you will. And so by the time I came to his convention, which was in San Francisco in 1973.
Yes.
There were other issues that had to be dealt with. There were a lot of young lawyers, especially women lawyers who were dissatisfied with the way the ball was going at that time.
And we who had been in the movement or who had been influenced by the movement were steeped in the tradition of democracy. We wanted people to be involved in a lot of decisions that they weren't.
The National Bar Association was kind of like an imperial potentate kind of arrangement. You, the president, you the man. You did what you damn well, please.
So we elected two things happened at time, visa video, young lawyers. We elected a new treasurer.
I think you joined up from Florida, the lawyer from Florida. And I became elected to the board at that, at that particular time.
Now that was, that was a, that was the first two things. But we also, I also revised along with some friends. We revived the young lawyers division, which had been started once, but had died down.
We revived that. That was our vehicle. And I drew upon the knowledge I had that the people around the country that I had been calling, some of whom were young, some of whom were not so young to make that organization very viable.
So to make a long story short, we became, the young lawyers became a campaign enterprise for young and aspiring lawyers who wanted to see some change come about.
To make the bar more interested in issues than just, than just conspicuous consumption amongst some very prominent black attorneys as it had become.
So the next year in Chicago, I ran for fourth vice president. Then the next year, somewhere I ran for third vice president. And then second vice president. And it was time for me to run for president elect.
Nobody ran against me because I had the young lawyers as a basis plus the women lawyers. Because I believe the women lawyers in 74 were formed. And it was like a complete overlap.
Because the women who were in the women's division were also in the young lawyers division. So we always had a coalition.
And we were able to go into each of the large delegations. And we were off a trade-offs. You support our candidates. We support yours.
So that's that way I parlayed my way up to becoming president elect. And so in Florida of 1978, I became the youngest person ever elected to the National Bar Association because I was only 34 years old.
And immediately we began to do things on a collective basis. The most important thing was to introduce to the National Bar Association the whole concept of the freedom, the independence of southern Africa.
So they had never done that before. One of my friends from SNCC was very influential in this next move.
We knew that the races in southern Rhodesia were trying to prop able moves of wear up as the next God coming for African independence.
But they really weren't going to give them any independence. The Constitution really kept all the power for the whites. And everybody knew that. But we were lawyers and we knew how to say it.
So my international affairs committee dissected that and did a very wonderful paper.
The guy who is now the head of the NAACP Legal Defense Fund was the head of that committee whose name I just cannot think of. This is terrible going into historical record. I couldn't think of his name.
No, Theodore M. Shaw was not. Theodore M. Shaw was gone before that. It was Julius LeVonne Chambers and I think Elaine R. Jones, Theodore M. Shaw. And now this guy, John, John, he'll come to me in a minute. Sorry, John.
So the committee, you know, otherwise, you know, it was a very legally scholarly document. And we knew we had something. But it was just going to be another document. So I call my friends from SNCC.
And I asked, can we get this before the United Nations, African group, the organization of African unity. So we were able to go to the United Nations.
The organization heard what we had to say. There was a rush for copies. Not only did the OAU accepted. But it was adopted by the General Council of the United Nations as an official document of the United Nations only question of independence for Zimbabwe.
And it was translated into seven languages and sent all around the world. Friend of mine from Ghana, sent me an article, front page, lead article in the Ghanaian Times, black lawyers, champion, Africa rights or something like that. So it was, it was like my movement days were coming true.
You know, here we were involved with African independence as African Americans. And for a long time, there was a great deal of unity between the Africans who were in the United Nations and eventually the ones in Washington who were diplomats of a higher level as everybody sought that paper.
I went to Jamaica, but another one of the United Nations committees and everybody wanted a copy. I got invited to Cuba because of that paper, which I eventually did a year later.
I had an idea to bring lawyers and doctors and nurses and pharmacists, not pharmacists, dentists to Zimbabwe. That got shot down because the Zimbabwean ambassador when Zimbabwe did become independent. They were very grateful for what I had done, what we had done.
He didn't call me back in time for me to get this forward grant that I had set up for Vice President.
Says, Mr. Williams, this thing is going to die unless we get the Zimbabwe government to agree and he never got back to me. So that they didn't want it. He just didn't see the importance of this whole thing.
So the good part of it was that I was able to parlay this paper on behalf of the NBA into a position where black lawyers could really help in the independence of Zimbabwe.
And here's the crowning achievement was my people in the White House got the document to Jimmy Carter and got him to hold on to sanctions because of the document. That's what we were told.
So that was probably the most significant aspects of what I did when I was president. That movement connection was there because we were able to organize the people.
But also we always kept our focus with our eyes on the prize. Right after that. So that was over in 1979 had a great convention in Los Angeles.
And for my keynote speaker I had Louis Farrakhan, who wild and mesmerized the people that was a hush when I walked down the aisle with him to bring him into the first plenary session.
I had met him in New Haven when I was up there. He was the Muslim minister in charge of the mosque there. That's another story. But he wild him. He spoke for about an hour and everybody gave him about.
And it was the most of the been at least 10 standing novations when he got finished. He was he had everybody in the palm of his hand.
So that's how I went out next year. I went to Cuba the following year. I went to Harvard for the I call Paul oversoil who was my friend from state here in New Jersey.
And if you remember from College of Medicine and Dentistry of New Jersey of New Jersey he was then the dean of the education school. So he said I got something for you.
I said I'm tired and eat something to do. So he got me in Institute of Politics at the John F. Kennedy School of Government, Harvard for a semester.
So I was beginning to believe that I've been along there. I told him Miami riot occurred. I wrote an article for the New York Times. I wrote an op-ed pace. That was my first op-ed peace anywhere.
And that kind of brought me back to earth. So I said I got to use all these skills and the talents I have to go back to New York and what can I do?
Gibson had been there for then going on 12 years. Very little had changed. He had not used the power in the street to match that power which he had in the suite to force any kind of real change.
For example he's raising taxes. The state was not giving enough money. Kind of like it is right now. So here he was saying I'll take whatever the state will allow and still begging for money from the Fed.
And it wasn't coming because now we were in the age of Reaganomics. So the power of the people was divorced from the power of the institutions that we had created an entree to.
They had English but you got the point. So I wanted to correct that. And I wanted to create another movement to get me in there so that I could make sure that the independent organizations that had been killed by Gibson could be revived.
And we could once again get the kind of power we needed to back up the folks who had been elected and put into office. Obviously I didn't win.
I didn't have the money he had. There were other people running to I didn't have anywhere near the money that was necessary. People told me I should have run for council first but I thought the time was now City Council.
I thought the time was now and once I got involved in that whole process and I saw what you needed to do to raise money. I realized that was not me. I couldn't do that.
Because you have to be kind of like all things to all people and I wasn't that I was for the people who don't quote. And I knew what that took. And I was interested in people empowering people. I was interested in people becoming a part of the process just as I always had been.
So I realized that was not the vehicle that was cut out for me because I would never be able to raise that kind of money.
So that answered your question.
I was the town attorney in Irvington.
I was the town attorney in Irvington because I had a good friend Sara Bost who became mayor and she originally asked me to be council for the City Council where she was president of the council in Irvington.
Which is the town next over from New Town of about 50,000 mostly black. And then when she became mayor I helped her in her election. She asked me to be the town attorney.
So once she decided, excuse me, not to run again. I decided I was going to do something here and knew once again.
There was a program called Abbott v. Burke which was in trouble. It was always in trouble right from the onset. In 1981 a group called Education Law Center followed suit saying that you have to match the money state of New Jersey.
You have to match the money that the suburban schools are getting. You have to match the money that they're getting and put that into urban schools.
I don't know if they came up right because it's getting late in the day. I want to try it again.
Is that a claim of the state constitution? Well it was based on the state constitution which has thorough and efficient" in its language. And so the constitutional claim was upheld by seven white men over the age of 50 with a whole lot of money. They saw it. They said we have to have in the city the same amounts of money that they spend in the suburbs not just the average amount but the higher.
The higher suburbs of paying that's what we need to have real school reform and they prescribed a school reform program which has supplemental programs which if necessary and they always were you have to pay more state of New Jersey.
So now no governor since that time has agreed to that in total. Democrat Republican. So I said it's time to get the parents involved so to make a long story short I went to some foundations and I said we're going to build this organization that Rutgers based upon our ability to teach people how to become involved.
We're not going to have an organization but we're going to teach people how to get organized. So I have been able to bring all of my skills and all of my memories and all of my ability to help people strategize to do different things.
Whether it's on a little school basis or whether it's to help save the average program or whether it's to now helping young people to become involved in the process.
I said we've got older people involved as parents let's get the ultimate beneficiaries in here because when I was that age I was thinking about becoming a member of SNCC.
No such thoughts have been going on regularly on the part of young people today. They have been spontaneous outbursts. They have been people who want to mobilize to do different things. I'm not saying nobody's conscious because they are but the whole concept of organization has been lost.
It was lost when we put all of our eggs in the basket of electing black politicians and those black politicians turning around and destroyed the organizational base that brought them over.
So there's a whole brand new group of people out here don't know anything about SNCC and core and end cup and NAPA and how we got over and how we did what we did. So that's my job. I'm teaching a whole new generation what we did and everything I've been talking to you about for the last three hours we've been talking about in one way or another in those classes.
I am very excited about both groups. The parents getting organized more and more or not just because we're doing it parents organizing all the time.
But what we're trying to do is to help those parents who are so inclined to get involved. We're teaching them that there's a certain way you use information. There's a certain way that you position yourself. There's a certain set of strategies that you can use to make your presence more profitable in terms of the goals that you have.
With the young people who are saying to them, you have a voice and your voice deserves to be heard. And if you learn the skills of the media your voice can be amplified.
Now first part of that is the most difficult. A lot of young people have been so beat down they don't think they have a voice.
Must last that it should be heard. But we introduced that whole concept and once you open the door with them, boom, they walk through.
So now we got a whole lot of young advocates here who know how to speak. They know how to interview. They know how to use cameras. Not quite as expensive as that one.
They know how to put projects together. They know how to put we haven't taught them how to edit. Hopefully we'll do that this summer. It's a summer program on an intense basis five days four days a week and it's bringing in the fall. It's two days a week after school.
And they introduced a lot of documents that a lot of people have paid attention to short public service announcements to longer documentaries.
We've got some young people who have graduated and who now come back here and help us as interns. We've got some young people who have graduated and I meet them in the store or something they say, you know, because of that program, I went to college and now I'm really doing some advocacy things in college.
So we planted a seed that's that's being watered every day by the events of the time.
I know there's even more history, much more history that we could discuss, but today you have been just a remarkable generous and what a pleasure. So it's been an honor and a privilege. Thank you for such a generous and substantive contribution to this year.
Well, I hope everybody runs out and reads my book once it gets published. It's called Unfinished Agenda: Urban Politics in the Era of Black Power and hopefully it will be produced. It will be published by Smith Sony. So let's hope so.
Thank you so much.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.